Ja, ich hab gestern auch, als wir so ganz hart gefeiert hatten, hab ich 3 Glas Wein getrunken, aber halbe nur. Ich weiß ja, was auf mich zukommt und dementsprechend verhalte ich mich.
Wir haben ein Defizit an Durchblick und an...
Wer hat den?
Sie als Aufsichtsrat oder...
Wir haben ein Defizit alle an Durchblick.
Weder ich noch einer meiner Familienangehörigen sind oder waren in irgendeiner Form an einer Spielerberatungsagentur beteiligt. Weiterhin haben weder ich noch einer meiner Familienangehörigen jemals Geld oder andere finanzielle Zuwendungen durch einen Spielertransfer erhalten. Das bedeutet aber im Umkursschluss, meine lieben Freunde, dass ich jeden, der etwas anders behaupte, ab sofort strafrechtlich verfolgen werde.
Genau, also in der Kombination mit dieser Steuernachzahlung in Höhe von 8,9 Millionen Euro und eben der ausufernden Kosten für das WM Stadion war klar, dass der FCK damals mit circa 40 Millionen Euro verschuldet, in dieser Form nicht überleben würde. Und das wäre auch damals anders ausgegangen, weil dieses Planinsolvenzverfahren, was der FCK jetzt im Jahr 2020 anstrebt, sowas hat die Insolvenzordnung damals noch nicht vorgesehen. Das heißt, eine Fortführung eines Unternehmens nach einer Insolvenz, die war eigentlich nicht angedacht. Das heißt, den FCK hätte es in dieser Form nicht mal gegeben. Doch letztlich ist die Stadt, das Land, die Politik so gesehen in die Bresche gesprungen. Das Stadion wurde dem FCK abgekauft für ca. 66 Millionen Euro. Dafür wurde eine Objektgesellschaft gegründet. Die Fritz-Walter-Stadion-GmbH, hat Sebastian vorhin schon mal kurz gesagt, ist eine 100%ige Tochter der Stadt Kaiserslautern. Und der FCK war fortan nicht mal Eigentümer, sondern Mieter in den heiligen Hallen oder auf dem heiligen Rasen, besser gesagt auf dem Betzenberg. Doch es wurde damals eben ein ganz ganz großer Fehler gemacht. Und zwar der Pachtvertrag, der damals abgeschlossen worden ist. Der hat damals eine Pachtsumme von jährlich 3,2 Millionen Euro vorgesehen. Ja, aber den Fallabstieg, 2. Liga oder 4. Liga, war nie vorgesehen. Das zeigt ja schon, wo die Probleme in den nächsten Jahren hingeführt haben.
Müssen wir an der Stelle dann auch über Kurt Beck sprechen? Wie kam denn das zustande, Sebastian? Dieses Einspringen der Stadt? Und Kurt Beck hat ja auch damals die Jahreshauptversammlung 2002 geleitet, in der dann ein neuer Vorstand gewählt werden musste. Da war ja kurz der FCK führungslos. Und dann hat es erstmal jemanden gebraucht, der überhaupt die Versammlung leiten kann.
Man muss natürlich zunächst mal wissen, Kurt Beck, der ehemalige Ministerpräsident von Rheinland-Pfalz, war und ist einfach auch ein sehr großer FCK-Fan. Das heißt, der war regelmäßig zugegen bei den Spielen. Es gibt auch berühmte Fernsehaufnahmen, wie er mit Norbertines damals in Leverkusen auf der Tribüne sitzt und dem weinenden Norbertines Trost spendet, nachdem der FCK damals sehr dramatisch zum ersten Mal in die zweite Liga abgestiegen ist. Die Person Kurt Beck hatte wahrscheinlich persönlich auch großes Interesse daran, dass dem FCK geholfen wird. Aber das Land natürlich auch. Man hat natürlich seitens der Landesregierung, ich will nicht sagen, Druck gemacht, aber man hat schon Gas gegeben, weil man die WM auch unbedingt in Rheinland-Pfalz am Standort Kaiserslautern haben wollte. Das hat einen unglaublich großen Umbau. Das Stadion ist nach sich gezogen, da ja auch ein bisschen was gekostet hat. Ein paar Milöntchen, wo sich der FCK ja auch beteiligen sollte, was ja auch dann im Endeffekt dazu beigetragen hat, dass der FCK finanziell völlig aus dem Ruder gelaufen ist. Und deswegen hat Kurt Beck, denke ich, einfach so gehandelt, dass er da halt in die Bresche gesprungen ist. Und in seiner typischen Art, wie es damals war, er ist ja mittlerweile im Ruhestand, aber er war ja niemand, der leise Töne gespuckt hat. Sondern Kurt Beck war ja immer jemand, der nach vorne gegangen ist, der laut war, der dann bei Verhandlungen das Heft des Handelns an sich gerissen hat und es dann irgendwie geschafft hat, dem FCK ein paar Mal zu helfen und dann eben das auch eingetütet hat, dass das Stadion dann im Endeffekt an die Stadion-Gesellschaft ging oder mit eingetütet hat.
Ich glaube, wir müssen sagen, über die Art und Weise, wie damals der FCK gerettet worden ist, mit dieser Objekt-Gesellschaft, mit diesem Pachtvertrag usw., da ist sicher nicht alles richtig gelaufen und darüber lässt sich sicherlich diskutieren. Aber der Punkt, dass man das Stadion und den FCK retten musste, war angesichts der bevorstehenden WM, glaube ich, klar. Die WM war ein Riesenimpuls für die ganze Stadt, für die ganze Region Kaiserslautern, für die ganze Pfalz. Vieles wäre in Kaiserslautern heute nicht so, wäre die WM damals nicht da gewesen. Ich habe da auch mal ein paar Zahlen rausgesucht. Abseits des Stadions wurden allein Investitionen in Höhe von 150 Millionen Euro in Kaiserslautern rund um Kaiserslautern ausgelöst, die ohne die WM so nicht da gewesen wären. Das hat Kaiserslautern einen Schub gegeben, auch generell was die Anbindung angeht, was die Autobahnanbindung, was den Nahverkehr angeht. Davon hat Kaiserslautern noch Jahre danach profitiert. Nicht nur der Fußball, sondern jeder normale Bürger in der Stadt.
Ja, und profitiert bis heute. Ich meine, die Infrastrukturen werden ja teilweise immer noch genutzt. Es gibt riesige Park- und Rideparkplätze, die damals angelegt wurden. Die sind zwar heute nur noch spärlich gefüllt an Spieltagen, werden aber immer noch genutzt. Wie es Moritz auch schon gesagt hat, die ganze Infrastruktur auch in der Stadt. Das Erscheinungsbild der Stadt, wenn du zum Beispiel von der Autobahn runterfährst und fährst in die Stadt rein, hat sich ganz, ganz entscheidend zum Positiven damals auch einfach verändert, weil halt die Stadt sich einfach rausgeputzt hat für die WM. Und man muss auch sagen, die Leute, die diese WM-Zeit in Lautern damals mitbekommen haben, ich glaube, da gibt es wenig Leute, die sagen, sie wollen diese Zeit missen, weil ich habe das auch noch sehr, sehr gut in Erinnerung. Ich war damals noch sehr jung, wie wir alle drei, würde ich behaupten.
Also vor allem ihr beiden.
Das war einfach, naja, komm, so viel älter bist du ja auch nicht, aber das war einfach eine unglaublich schöne Zeit. Aber das war wahrscheinlich überall in Deutschland so. Es war einfach eine tolle Stimmung. Aber auch gerade in Kaiserslautern, das lag natürlich auch dran, wer dann da alles da war an Gastmannschaften, von Australien bis Hassenich gesehen, die waren alle super drauf. Und diese Zeit will keiner missen, nur dieser Ratten-Schwanz, der da dran hängt bis heute, holt den FCK immer wieder ein.
Und gerade diese örtlichen Gegebenheiten in Kaiserslautern waren ja auch der Punkt, den viele Fans aus der ganzen Welt, also Australien hast du gerade angesprochen, Trinidad und Topago war da, Paraguay war da. Das ist ja das, was die gelohnt haben, dass du von der Fan-Meile, diese ein Kilometer oder zwei Kilometer lange Fan-Meile, die einmal durch die Stadt gegangen ist, dass die quasi genau am Fuße des Betzenbergs geendet hat. Und du hast von der Fan-Meile bis zu in zehn Minuten hoch zum Stadion gekommen. Und das hast du ja in dieser Art und Weise in keiner anderen Stadt gehabt in Deutschland. Weil wenn ich jetzt mal München als Beispiel ranziehe, dann feierst du auf dem Marienplatz und setzt dich dann halt in die S-Bahn oder in die U-Bahn und fährst in die Arena raus.
Also schon eine Dreiviertelstunde später kann man eine Viertelstunde zum Stadion laufen.
Und dieses Kleine, dieses Kompakte, das ist ja das, was nahezu perfekt war dafür.
Das ist ja auch das, was so ein bisschen den Charme, sage ich mal, von Kaiserslautern ausmacht. Kaiserslautern schafft es ja auch immer gerade so, Großstadt zu sein. Großstadt ist man ja ab 100.000 Einwohnern. Da ist die Stadt auch ganz stolz darauf, dass sie diese Marke jetzt vor gar nicht allzu lange Zeit mal wieder geknackt hat. Das spielt ja auch finanziell eine Rolle. Man kriegt ja auch als Großstadt ein bisschen mehr Zuschüsse als eine kleinere Stadt. Es ist einfach das, was auch, glaube ich, die Kaiserslautern an der Stadt schätzen, dass es halt klein und übersichtlich ist. Du hast kurze Wege und, so wie es der Moritz gesagt hat, klar, das war damals einfach super, diese WM-Meile, das war wirklich die eine große Straße, die hochführt zum Betzenberg. Du kannst ihn quasi während du hochläufst aus der Stadt schon sehen, weil dieses Stadion natürlich über der Stadt drohend. Und das war natürlich perfekt und das haben alle damals gefeiert, die sie hier waren. Alle Gäste aus der ganzen Welt, auch bei uns, hatten aus Australia auf der Couch gepennt.
Ja, also das kann ich, das kann ich alles sehr gut nachvollziehen, auch ideell. Aber wenn wir jetzt vorhin darüber sprechen, dass Kaiserslautern auch eine der höchst verschuldeten Kommunen Deutschland ist, muss man da dann auch auf die WM 2006 mit zurückblicken. Also 150 Millionen Euro Investitionen müssen ja auch entsprechende langfristige Einnahmen entgegenstehen.
Das sind einfach auch ganz viele strukturelle Probleme. Ich habe das, glaube ich, in unserem Kurzpass schon mal versucht, so ein bisschen zu erklären. Ich kann es auch gerne jetzt nochmal machen. Das spielt da auch eine Rolle natürlich, aber da muss man teilweise noch viel weiter zurückgehen. Das würde jetzt hier auch viel zu weit führen, das alles auszuführen. Aber ganz kurz zusammengefasst, Kaiserslautern war eigentlich eine totale Industriestadt früher, mit einer Spinnerei. Hier gibt es auch nach wie vor ein Opel-Werk. Also es war eine Arbeiterstadt einfach. Und das hat sich sehr stark gewandelt. Man ist weggegangen von dieser Arbeiterstadt hin zu einem heutzutage Technologie-Standort. Hier gibt es ein Fraunhofer-Institut. Hier werden Apps entwickelt. Hier gibt es eine Technische Universität. Aber das hat natürlich dazu geführt, und ich glaube, dieserlei Probleme kennt man zum Beispiel im Ruhrpott auch, dass es natürlich unglaublich viele Leute gab, die irgendwann mal Jobs verloren haben, weil es halt diese Art der Arbeit nicht mehr gab, die unzufrieden waren. Es gab eine hohe Arbeitslosigkeit. Und ja, das ist einfach so eins der Grundprobleme. Und klar, wenn du dann natürlich noch so was hast wie ein FCK, der ständig viel Geld frisst, dann kommst du natürlich als Stadt in einen Abwärtsstudel, der nur sehr schwer zu bewältigen ist.
Ja, und dann ja auch, wenn wir zurückkommen auf den Verein, weil dann ja auch sportlich so einiges schief geht. Also wir waren im Jahr 2003, sind jetzt immer so ein bisschen gehüpft zwischen 2003 und 2006 und der aktuellen Zeit, aber da wurde quasi das Stadion verkauft und dieser Pachtvertrag aufgesetzt, der bemerkenswerterweise nicht mit der zweiten Liga geplant hat. Und genau das passiert dann aber im Jahr, in der Saison 2005-2006. Lautern wird 16. und steigt zum zweiten Mal in seiner Geschichte in die zweite Fußball-Bundesliga ab. Genau, also man hatte dann immerhin noch dieses emotionale Highlight. Und übrigens, Lautern war doch, hat nicht auch Italien gegen Australien, dieses Achtelfinale mit dem 1-0...
War auch in Kaiserslautern, ja.
Genau, das war auf dem Betzenberg, hab ich mich doch richtig erinnert. Also es wurde da sogar WM-Geschichte geschrieben. Aber im kommenden Jahr eben dann auch Zweitliga-Geschichte. Moritz, wenn wir uns jetzt mal an das Sportliche erinnern, wie ist denn das Sportliche jetzt eigentlich zustande gekommen, dass Lautern wieder abgestiegen ist? Kann man das an Namen festmachen? Was ist da jetzt so im Nachhinein deine Analyse?
Kann man das an Namen festmachen? Ich sage mal, mit der ganzen Krise einhergehend ist natürlich auch klar, dass das Budget Jahr für Jahr geschrumpft ist. Und der sportliche Abwärtstrudel, in dem man sich dann insbesondere in dieser Saison 2006 befunden hat, den konnte man dann halt auch nicht mal aufhalten. Obwohl die Mannschaft damals durchaus den ein oder anderen Spieler gehabt hat. Also der junge Halilaitin-Top damals in der Mannschaft gewesen. Ich müsste jetzt nochmal nachschauen, aber ich glaube, er hat auch relativ viele Tore geschossen in diesem Jahr. Ansonsten war die Mannschaft in diesem Abstiegsjahr 2006 auch von vielen jungen Spielern gespickt. Daniel Halfa, der ja auch später dann nochmal zum FCK zurückgekommen ist, unter anderem sei dabei. Aber alles in allem, es hat dann halt einfach nicht mal gereicht.
Spielt da dann auch sowas eine Rolle, wie das Miroslav Klose wurde ja in der Saison 2004-2005 verkauft. Und da fällt eben auf, dass es die erste Saison, in der man ein deutliches Transferplus hat beim FCK. Und wir haben ja schon über die Schulden gesprochen. Da scheint es mir, Sebastian, einen Zusammenhang zu geben. Ein geändertes Einkaufsverhalten.
Ja, aber bei Miroslav Klose muss man ja auch noch dazu. Sagen, dass der FCK ja vorher schon die Transferrechte an Lotto Rheinland-Pfalz abgedreht hat. Und die haben dann wiederum die Hose bekommen, die es für Klose damals gab. Also das kommt auch noch dazu. Du siehst, wir kommen immer wieder an Punkte, an die du dich auch noch erinnerst. Aber es ist einfach so viel, dass man das teilweise wieder verdrängt. Eine Sache wollte ich auch noch zu dem Punkt vorher sagen. Das hat Moritz auch schon richtig angesprochen. Ich glaube, ein großes Problem auch in der Abstiegssaison damals war, dass zu viel Last auf jungen Spielern gelegen hat. Daniel Halfa, Fabian Schönheim, das waren alles damals gute Kicker. Und dann hieß es immer, wir haben natürlich auch Angst, dass wir die verbrennen. Aber die sollten dann im Endeffekt doch irgendwie die Kohlen aus dem Feuer holen. Und haben das nicht geschafft und sind an diesem Druck auch einfach zerbrochen. Und dann natürlich ja auch, muss man ja auch sagen, es war ja nicht so, dass man da irgendwie sang- und klanglos abgestiegen ist, sondern natürlich, wie es zum FC Kaiserslautern passt, dramatisch da bei diesem Saisonfinale in Wolfsburg.
Warst du damals dort, Sebastian?
Ich war tatsächlich in Wolfsburg.
Ich war tatsächlich auch da. Ich weiß noch...
Das ist jetzt so, wie wenn sich Vietnamveteran miteinander unterhalten.
Da habe ich mich nachher auch mal bei meiner Mama bedankt, weil auch wenn ich jetzt den FC Kaiserslautern journalistisch begleite, als gebürtiger Kaiserslautere, habe ich natürlich auch keine andere Wahl gehabt und war natürlich auch großer FC Kaiserslautern-Fan. Ich war damals bei dem Spiel zwölf Jahre alt. Natürlich sind mir nach dem Abpfiff auch die Tränen gekommen. Meine Mama hat sich damals vor mich gestellt. Sie hat gesagt, dass ich nicht die Kameras des Sportstudios einprang. Und ich als Symbolbild, wir kennen ja alle diese Symbolbilder, von weinenden Fans, noch Jahre später herhalten muss.
Ich war damals mit zwei Kollegen da. Ich war schon ein bisschen älter, ich war 19. Die Tickets waren natürlich sehr begehrt. Wir hatten Karten für den Wolfsburg-Block und haben dann kulanterweise vor Ort von den Ordnern die getauscht bekommen in irgendwelche Ausweichtickets für den FCK-Bereich, was doch eine ganz gute Idee war.
Okay, das sind so die Geschichten aus dem Schützengraben jetzt. Ich nenne noch kurz zwei Namen dazu. Denn was jetzt auch so langsam einsetzt, eigentlich schon eingesetzt hat, ist eine zunehmende Rotation auf dem Trainerstuhl, was sich jetzt immer mal wieder beschleunigen wird. Also wir hatten quasi, im Grunde endet das mit Otto Rehages Rücktritt im Jahr 2000. Dann kam Andreas Brehme, das war noch eine längere Phase. Aber jetzt geht es dann so langsam los mit Eric Gerrads. Hat man noch jemanden, der zwei Jahre im Amt ist? Dann kommt Kurt Jarra, der ist ein Jahr im Amt. Und dann Michael Henke, der eben eine sehr kurze Amtszeit hat und eben in dieser Abstiegssaison entlassen wird, im November schon. Sein Nachfolger wird dann Wolfgang Wolf.
Michael Henke war halt wirklich aus der heutigen Sicht ein totaler Fehlgriff. Man hat halt irgendwie gedacht, dass Michael Henke das, was er als Co-Trainer von Ottmar Hitzfeld bei den Bayern und bei Dortmund gelernt hat, auch als Cheftrainer selbst irgendwo auf den Rasen übertragen kann. Aber dem war ja nichts so. Und er ist ja auch nach diesem kurzen 15-Spiele-Intermezzo nicht mal groß als Cheftrainer in Erscheinung getreten.
Nee, ich glaube, Michael Henke ist ein guter Co-Trainer, aber kein Cheftrainer.
Wer war denn damals die sportliche Leitung, die dann entschieden hat, Michael Henke unter anderem zu holen und dann auch den Kader entsprechend zusammenzustellen, wie du es schon vorhin angedeutet hast, Sebastian?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Das habe ich jetzt gerade nicht mehr parat. Da kann mir bestimmt der Moritz helfen. Wer war damals sportliche Leitung?
Ich bin auch gerade am Überlegen.
Okay, ehrlich gesagt, das tröstet mich total. Die Träne habe ich mir noch aufgerufen in einem eigenen Tabak. Aber dadurch, dass es so oft gewechselt hat zwischen Sportdirektor, Geschäftsführer, Sport, sportlicher Leitung, hätte ich es nicht mehr so genau sagen können.
Lassen wir das als... Ich glaube, das steht relativ symptomatisch dafür, dass du so einen krassen Personalwechsel über die Jahre hattest. Dass, ich glaube, die wenigsten es tatsächlich noch schaffen würden, aus dem Stand wirklich alle aufzuzählen.
Das ist schon wirklich verrückt, dass man quasi mit Experten über einen Verein spricht. Aber nicht mal böse sein kann, wenn sich da jemand nicht dran erinnert. Das ist tatsächlich ein bisschen stellvertretend. Ich versuch's jetzt irgendwie nebenher dann doch noch rauszufinden, weil ich uns jetzt in eine ungute Lage gebracht hab mit meiner Nachfrage entschuldigt dafür. Ich dachte, wenn man da im Schützengraben lag... Ach Gott, jetzt sehe ich hier auch wieder nur die Trainer-Historie. Die hilft mir doch nichts. Ich weiß doch, dass dann Wolfgang Wolf kam. Es ist wirklich schlimm. Jetzt bin ich wieder bei den Trainern gelandet, zum 100. Mal schon. Gut, also dann...
Vielleicht machen wir einfach weiter.
Ja, vielleicht machen wir einfach weiter. Es tut mir leid. Irgendwann kam ja dann... Na gut, egal. Es geht runter in die zweite Liga. Da wird sich der FC Kaiserslautern für ein paar Jahre tummeln. Nämlich von der Saison 2006, 2007 an bis zum Aufstieg 2009, 2010. Und da gab es ja zwischenzeitlich eher... Also der Aufstieg 2010 war deshalb so bemerkenswert unter Marco Kurz dann, weil man der dritten Liga an der Stelle schon so nah war. Es kam zum Sašić-Wunder und dem Regen, dem Fritz-Walter-Wetter am 34. Spieltag. Sašić hat, glaube ich, sieben Punkte aus den letzten Spielen, also sieben Punkte Rückstand aufgeholt und so den FCK zum ersten Mal vor dem Fall in die dritte Liga gerettet. Kann man denn irgendwie abschätzen, Moritz, was das mit dem Verein gemacht hätte, wenn es an der Phase schon schiefgegangen wäre? Hätten wir dann vielleicht etwas, was wir jetzt erlebt haben, schon zehn Jahre früher mitbekommen?
Ich glaube, das müssen wir nicht nur abschätzen. Ich glaube, das können wir recht konkret sagen. Also ein Abstieg in die dritte Liga hätte der FCK aus wirtschaftlicher Sicht im Jahr 2008 wahrscheinlich nicht überlebt. Das hätte zu einer Insolvenz geführt. Und meines Wissens war auch im Jahr 2008 die Insolvenzordnung nun nicht so, wie sie jetzt ist. Das heißt, wir hätten wieder das gleiche Szenario, das wir vorhin schon für das Jahr 2003 angesprochen haben.
Also Milan Sašić, derjenige, dem man da eine Statue bauen kann. Sebastian, kann man dann festmachen, wie sich der FC K sportlich dann in dieser Zeit entwickelt hat? Du hast ja vorhin schon den jungen Kader angesprochen.
Meinst du jetzt speziell unter Sašić oder generell in der Zeit?
Nee, in dieser Phase. Also Sašić, das war natürlich eine schöne Geschichte. Vor allem, das war ja auch noch, also wenige Spiele vor dieser Rettung stand, die ja noch die komplette Mannschaft vor der Tribüne und musste sich beschimpfen lassen. Aber Sašić hat sich vor die Mannschaft gestellt und dann haben sie eben in dramatischer Art und Weise diese Wende geschafft. Aber ich würde es jetzt eben nicht nur auf diese Saison festmachen, sondern wir wissen quasi, wir kommen aus dieser glorreichen Rehagelzeit. Dann holt man sich tolle Namen, man holt sich tolle Namen. Dann muss man sehr viel Schulden bezahlen, wo sich später rausstellt, hätte man vielleicht gar nicht bezahlen sollen. Logischerweise verkauft man dann eher Spiele und hat vielleicht noch den Fehler gemacht, vom größten Talent neben Michael Ballack, was man hatte, die Transferrechte dann schon vorher zu verkaufen. Und diese wirtschaftlichen Probleme, die schlagen jetzt ja immer wieder auch auf den sportlichen Bereich durch. Das ist ja nicht mehr voneinander zu trennen. Was ist das jetzt für eine lautere Mannschaft, die wir in dieser Phase dann erleben, in diesen 4 Zweitligasaisons?
Ich glaube, dann hat man es schon Step by Step geschafft, mit den natürlich wenigen Mitteln, die man damals hatte, aber natürlich immer noch mehr als heutzutage, auf Dauer eine Einheit zu formen. Und ich glaube, das war tatsächlich diese Phase, auch dann die Jahre kurz vor dem Wiederaufstieg in die Bundesliga und dann auch das eine Jahr, in dem man sich in der Bundesliga gehalten hat. Das war so die letzte Phase, an die ich mich erinnern kann, wo man meines Erachtens nach sagen kann, dass das wirklich ein Team war, dass das eine Einheit war, eine eingespielte Truppe, dass du einfach auch Spieler hattest, die, glaube ich, über ihren Verhältnissen gespielt haben, die aber in der Truppe, in der Gemeinschaft gut funktioniert haben. Dass du dann, keine Ahnung, Spieler wie Martin Amedik hattest oder dann später auch Christian Tiffert, der sich dann in der einen Bundesliga-Saison zum Vorlagen-Weltmeister, sage ich, hätte ich jetzt fast gesagt, entwickelt hat, aber der beste Vorlagegeber Florian Dick, der ein Bombentyp ist, ein super Charakter, mit dem ich jederzeit gerne bei seinen Eltern in dem Restaurant bei Karlsruhe unten in der Kegelbahn eine Runde kegeln und ein Bier trinken würde, aber der sicher auch nicht, bei allem Respekt, der beste Fußballer ist. Aber die haben, glaube ich, dann auch einfach alle das Maximum aus sich rausgekitzelt. Und ich glaube, das war in dieser Phase natürlich vor allem auch Marco Kurz geschuldet als Trainer. Weil Milan Sassic, da muss man auch dazu sagen, das war kein klassischer Fußballtrainer. Ich glaube, das war ein, in Anführungszeichen, Motivator, der aber eher mit Angst gespielt hat. Der mit Angst gespielt hat und der, glaube ich, seine Spieler so weit eingeschüchtert hat. Ich habe da auch mit einigen im Nachgang gesprochen, auch gerade noch gar nicht so lange her aus der alten Mannschaft. Die hatten einfach regelrecht Angst. Die hatten Angst, wenn sie versagen, dann kriegen sie vom Sašić richtig einen reingedrückt. Und da sind auch, glaube ich, ein paar Kabinentüren, diesen Wutanfällen zum Opfern gefallen, so der Sage nach. Aber das war, wie gesagt, in meinen Augen kein Fußballtrainer im klassischen Sinne, sondern da ging es eher um die Emotionen.
Oder zu sehr im klassischen Sinne, also kein moderner Fußballtrainer.
Kann auch sein, genau. Aber Marco Kurz hat es dann, glaube ich, geschafft, aus diesem Haufen eine Einheit zu formen, die ja dann auch tatsächlich zumindest eine Zeit lang gut zusammen funktioniert hat, bis man dann, und das hat neulich tatsächlich Tobias Sippel, der ehemalige FCK-Torwart, auch in einem Interview gesagt, ich weiß jetzt leider nicht mehr genau, wo es war, sonst hätte ich es auch gewürdigt, wo es war, der gesagt hat, man hat dann auch unnötigerweise wieder viel Geld für neue Spieler ausgegeben, statt die Mannschaft zu versuchen, so zusammenzulassen, wie sie war und wie sie funktioniert hat.
Welche Rolle spielt denn in diesem Komplex auch die Jugendarbeit vom 1. FC Kaiserslautern? Das wird ja an dem einen oder anderen Namen, den wir schon haben, fallen lassen, Michael Ballack, Miroslav Klose und natürlich müssen wir die ganzen Torhüter nennen, von Kevin Trapp über Tobias Sippe hast du ja genannt usw. Welche Rolle spielt die für den FCK in dieser Phase und welche Rolle spielt sie heute?
Die Jugendarbeit, die Nachwuchsabteilung spielt eine ganz wichtige Rolle, auch in den Jahren darauf, weil der FCK aufgrund seines wirtschaftlichen Defizits, über das wir ja schon ausführlich gesprochen haben, eigentlich immer auf Transfererlöse angewiesen war. Und da kam es ihm natürlich extrem zugute, dass aus den eigenen Reihen immer wieder jemand rauskam, durch die Torhüter angesprochen. Kevin Drapp damals nach Frankfurt hat auch über 1,5 Millionen Euro eingebracht, was damals vergleichsweise in der 2. Liga auch noch mehr Geld war, als es heute ist. Und auch später Willi Orban damals dann der Wechsel nach Leipzig. Robin Koch der Wechsel nach Freiburg. Da sind wir jetzt ja schon viel weiter gedanklich. Aber Jean Zimmer zum VfB Stuttgart damals für 2 Millionen. Robin Koch sogar 4 Millionen damals eingebracht nach Freiburg. Ohne die Jugendabteilung der FCK war quasi angewiesen. Um es kurz und knapp so zu sagen.
Die Jugendarbeit hat dem FCK mehrfach sowohl sportlich als auch finanziell den Arsch gerettet. Ich glaube, so kann man es schon relativ treffend zusammenfassen. Weil, ich sag mal, die fetten Jahre waren ja schon lange rum. Und es war kein Geld mehr da, um jetzt irgendwie Leute einzukaufen, die qualitativ so gut sind, um direkt einzuschlagen, die Mannschaft führen zu können. Das Geld hatte man damals schon nicht mehr. Also war man natürlich darauf angewiesen, zusätzlich zu einem glücklichen Händchen auf dem Transfermarkt auch sich immer wieder punktuell mit Leuten aus dem eigenen Nachwuchs zu verstärken. Umso trauriger ist es eigentlich, dass dann zwischendurch das NLZ nicht die Aufmerksamkeit und die Liebe bekommen hat, die es vielleicht verdient hätte. Es hätte ja auch schon längstens eigentlich, aber da sind wir dann schon wieder zu sehr in der Gegenwart bzw. in den erst kürzlich vergangenen Jahren. Es hätte ja schon längst auch ausgebaut werden sollen. Das ist ja auch, auch wenn natürlich der FCK sagt, hier schaut her, wir sind wieder ausgezeichnet worden, wir haben die höchste Anzahl an Sternen und so. Das ist alles klar, aber das ist natürlich nicht in einem Zustand, wie man sich das eigentlich wünscht für ein Nachwuchsleistungszentrum. Rein baulich und infrastrukturell.
Kann man die Situation vom 1. FC Kaiserslautern da dann vielleicht mit der von 1860 München vergleichen, die auch immer wieder tolle Spieler aus dem eigenen Nachwuchs nach oben gebracht haben, aber sobald die einen Funken Talent gezeigt haben, wurden sie abgegeben und man konnte sich dem nicht entgegenstemmen, weil man auch das Geld letztlich gebraucht hat?
Absolut. Absolut. Du warst halt einfach auch selten oder eigentlich nie in der Lage, solche Spieler dann mal zu halten. Man male sich das nur mal aus, wie der Kader aussehen würde oder wo der FCK stehen könnte, wenn diese ganzen Talente mal geblieben wären. Wir haben vorhin schon einen Namen gehört. Das ist natürlich ein Problem. Wir springen immer wieder in den Jahren vor und zurück, aber ich glaube, das greift alles so sehr ineinander über, dass man das machen muss. Aber allein ein Willy Orban, wenn du solche Spieler immer noch hättest, oder selbst ein John Zimmer, der ist natürlich kein überdurchschnittlicher Bundesligaspieler geworden ist, aber das sind Spieler, wenn du die hättest länger halten können, hättest du natürlich einen qualitativ viel stärkeren Kader gehabt.
Wenn du in der Abwehr aktuell wählen könntest zwischen Willy Orban, Dominik Heinz und Robin Koch in der Innenverteidigung, glaube damit, wäre der eine oder andere Bundesligist sehr zufrieden.
Ja, das tut jetzt natürlich ein bisschen weh, ist auch ein bisschen sehr theoretisch, aber das verdeutlicht ja ganz gut die Situation. Wir haben jetzt Marco Kurz schon genannt, wir haben den überraschenden Aufstieg in die 1. Liga genannt, der dann eben in der Saison 2009, 2010 erfolgte, als Erster der 2. Liga, also das war auch ein sehr souveräner Aufstieg. Eine Personalie haben wir jetzt nur vorhin schon in einem anderen Kontext angesprochen, nämlich Stefan Kunz, der kam ja 2008 dazu und hat dann ja die sportlichen Entscheidungen getroffen und ist zu meinem Gefühl nach Sebastian eine der Persönlichkeiten, wo sich die Meinungen dann wieder ganz schnell spalten, wie man jetzt seine Zeit beim FCK bewerten soll.
Ganz extrem, ganz extrem. Es gibt beim FCK zwei Lager, nämlich eins Pro-Kunz und eins Kontra-Kunz. Das muss man ganz einfach so sagen. Es gibt immer noch ganz viele Menschen, die Stefan Kunz unglaublich dankbar sind und ihn quasi absolut mit dieser Zeit identifizieren, mit dieser Rettung 2008, die er da zusammen mit Sazic quasi vollbracht hat. Und ganz berühmt ist ja auch diese Herzblutkampagne. Damals, als Stefan Kunz vorgestellt wurde, dann hat er diese Herzblutkampagne direkt mit vorgestellt. Und das Herzblut und das Herz der Pfalz. Das hat was entfacht. Und das ist eine Gabe, die Stefan Kunz ohne Zweifel hat. Und ich habe auch schon viele, viele Gespräche mit ihm geführt. Und kann das auf jeden Fall so bestätigen. Stefan Kunz hat diese Gabe, Menschen zu motivieren, Menschen von etwas zu überzeugen, Menschen auf seine Seite zu ziehen. Ob man das jetzt vielleicht auch teilweise negativ auslegen will, das muss jeder für sich entscheiden. Aber der kann einfach was aus Menschen rauskitzeln. Und der weiß auch, welchen Ton er treffen muss. Der weiß auch, an welcher Stelle er wie zu den Leuten sprechen muss. Du hast ja auch im Intro drin gehabt, diese Rede auf der JHV. Dafür gab es dann auch, das war dann im Intro natürlich nicht mehr zu hören, aber da gab es ja tausenden Applaus auch dafür. Also der Stefan Kunz wusste einfach immer, welchen Ton er jetzt treffen muss. Und ja, also wie gesagt, das hat natürlich dazu geführt, dass ganz, ganz lange unglaublich viele FCK-Fans Stefan Kunz absolut gefeiert haben und ihm total dankbar waren, dass er den FCK wieder in eine bessere Zukunft geführt hat. Aber es gab dann irgendwann, als es dann auch nicht mehr so lief, auch total viele Vorwürfe gegen seine Person. Das ist eigentlich ganz praktisch, dass du das auch im Intro drin hast. Da gab es dann die Vorwürfe, er hätte sich da an Spielertransfers bereichert, was er dann, wie wir im Intro gehört haben, vehement bestritten hat. Und ich glaube, irgendwann war dann auch einfach die Zeit vorbei. Irgendwann war es dann auch einfach an der Zeit für einen Wechsel. Und wie gesagt, es gibt bis heute nicht die eine einhellige Meinung unter den Fans, ob das jetzt durchweg positiv oder durchweg negativ war. Aber man muss natürlich sagen, Stefan Kunz könnte sich jetzt hinstellen und sagen, als ich noch da war, lief es zwar vielleicht auch nicht ganz optimal, aber deutlich besser als jetzt.
Ja gut, wobei ich könnte mich auch hinstellen und könnte sagen, also, gib mir mal den FC K für einen Tag und dann sage ich auch, es läuft jetzt besser, als es jetzt in den letzten Tagen lief.
Ich glaube, zusammenfassend kann man nicht sagen, Stefan Kunz hat den Verein damals wiederbelebt, als er im Jahr 2008 gekommen ist mit Milan Sašić damals. Nicht nur die sportliche Wende, sondern auch auf wirtschaftlicher Seite der Verein war absolut am Boden. Hätte im Jahr 2008 damals auch nicht der Hauptsponsor, damals die Deutsche Vermögensberatung, auf Forderungen verzichtet und gleichzeitig die Stadt Kaiserslautern weitere Stundungen bei der Stadionpacht zugelassen, dann wäre der Insolvenzantrag damals auch nicht zu vermeiden gewesen. Und aus dieser Lage hat er den Club eben wieder rausgeführt. Sebastian hat es, glaube ich, sehr gut beschrieben, mit welcher Art und Weise. Jürgen Klopp wird ja auch ganz oft als Menschenfänger bezeichnet, auch wenn er selbst diesen Begriff ja gar nicht so sehr mag. Aber ich glaube, auf Stefan Kunz trifft das in gewisser Weise auch zu.
Das Interessante ist ja, dass Stefan Kunz die eine personelle Konstante ist. Im Endeffekt wird er acht Jahre beim 1. FC Kaiserslautern gewesen sein. Wir beginnen jetzt im Jahr 2008, wir kommen im Jahr 2010 an, Aufstieg in die erste Liga. Es wird noch eine ganze Weile dauern, bis dann auch im Jahr 2016 sich Stefan Kunz vom FC K verabschiedet, mit allen Irrungen und Wirrungen dazwischen. Das finde ich ebenso interessant, weil das ist die eine Sache, die beim FC K konstant ist, ist der personelle Wechsel. Da scheint er so ein bisschen die Ausnahme zu sein, zumindest die sichtbare Ausnahme. Es gibt natürlich diejenigen in der zweiten Reihe, da hatten wir ja vorhin auch schon Beispiele genannt. Aber das finde ich eben einen interessanten Punkt, weil ich als Außenstehender immer das Gefühl habe, du kommst zum 1. FC Kaiserslautern als normale Persönlichkeit und du gehst als gebrochener Mann. Dieser Verein macht dich kaputt, egal mit welchen Absichten du gekommen bist und was du getan hast.
Diesen Eindruck kann ich total nachvollziehen. Und das kann ich nicht nur bei Trainern und Verantwortlichen nachvollziehen, auch bei Spielern. Wie oft passiert es, dass Spieler beim FC K gespielt haben, hier sich nicht wohlgefühlt haben, nicht ihr Potenzial abgerufen haben, dann wechseln und auf einmal Champions League spielen? Ein schönes Beispiel, was mir da immer einfällt, ist Kostas Fortunis, der hier zwar viele gute Ansätze gezeigt hat, aber ich glaube, nie so ganz sich zurechtgefunden hat, weil er zum Beispiel auch, ich weiß nicht, wie viele Jahre insgesamt da war, aber kein Wort Deutsch gesprochen hat, er hat nur Griechisch gesprochen, da musste immer ein Dolmetscher dazu. Und da gibt es unglaublich viele Beispiele, die genauso sind von Spielern, die dann, die beim FC K waren, dann vielleicht nicht ganz schlecht waren, aber auch nicht ganz so gut, dann gewechselt sind, und sobald sie woanders waren, total explodiert sind. Ein ganz aktuelles Beispiel ist auch, zum Beispiel Kerim Demirbay, der war nicht schlecht beim FC K, der war gut, aber man hatte damals schon öfter den Eindruck, der hat nicht immer so wirklich Bock, 100 Prozent zu geben. Und jetzt guckt euch an, was auch aus Kerim Demirbay geworden ist, in der Bundesliga, also gestandener Bundesligaspieler. Und da gibt es wirklich zig Beispiele. Und deswegen kann ich diesen Eindruck von außen stehen, total nachvollziehen, dass der FCK, wie hast du gesagt, ein Menschenfresser ist.
Welches Beispiel mir in dieser Hinsicht immer wieder einfällt, ist der Spieler Oliver Kirch. Ja, ja, damals auch beim FCK. Ich sage mal, wenn ich sage, er wurde nie geliebt, dann ist das noch sehr freundlich ausgedrückt. Man war gewissermaßen froh und hat sich auch damals sehr darüber gewundert, dass Jürgen Klopp ihn damals zum BVB geholt hat. Und natürlich wurde er auch beim BVB kein Stammspieler, aber das war, glaube ich, ihm bewusst und auch allen anderen Beteiligten. Aber er hat dann ein Spiel, und zwar im Viertelfinale der Champions League 2014 gegen Real Madrid gemacht, da hat Dortmund nach einer 3-0 Niederlage im Bernabeu dann zu Hause gespielt und Oliver Kirch hat im defensiven Mittelfeld gespielt und hat, ich glaube, das kann man wirklich sagen, das Spiel seines Lebens gemacht und hat die komplette Offensivabteilung von Real Madrid an diesem Tag, ja, matt gesetzt und wir reden da von Karim Genselmar, Gareth Bale, Di Maria und Co. Die haben keinen Stich gesetzt und jeder hat nur, also auch jeder FC K-Fan, den ich kenne, hat auf dieses Spiel geguckt und hat gesagt, wow.
So, Oliver Kirch, muss ich jetzt noch eine kleine Anekdote erzählen, die auch, glaube ich, Max freuen wird, nämlich einen Tickereintrag von Spox damals. Ich weiß nicht, ob es aus diesem Spiel war tatsächlich oder aus einem anderen Dortmundspiel, aber der Tickereintrag war Oliver Kirch mit seinem, keine Ahnung, 186., ob die es halt schon, weiß ich nicht, Ballkontakt, ein Hauch von Lionel Messi weht durch den Signal Iduna Paz. Das habe ich als Screenshot so oft mit so Leuten bekommen per WhatsApp, die gesagt haben, guck mal hier, Oliver Kirch, meinen die denselben Oliver Kirch, der auch beim FCK war? Also das war echt so ein Running Gag zu der Zeit.
Aber das ist ja vielleicht ein ganz guter Zeitpunkt, da mal die Frage zu stellen, was denn da den 1. FC Kaiserslautern so besonders macht und dann in dem Fall dann nicht unbedingt nur zum Guten. Also müssen wir dann auch um die Atmosphäre in der Stadt sprechen. Beim VfB Stuttgart wird ja gerne das angeblich so schwierige Umfeld zitiert. Beim HSV sind es die Medien und die Aufsichtsrats, die Aufsichtsratsmitglieder, die alle so schlimm sind. Wer ist jetzt beim FCK schuld, dass da nur gebrochene Menschen rauskommen?
Schwieriges Umfeld plus eins.
Aber ist das wirklich so oder ist das nur ein Meme?
Ich glaube, wir müssen vor allem über die Atmosphäre auch im Stadion sprechen. Auch weil ich das in persönlichen Gesprächen mit ehemaligen Spielern der letzten Jahre und auch der ein oder andere aus dem aktuellen Kader, dieses Stadion in Kaiserslautern mit dieser Westkurve, wenn die Westkurve voll ist, ist natürlich eine absolute Wucht. Wenn du da unten auf dem Rasen stehst, wenn dich da 15.000 Leute aus gesetzter Falle, es wäre ausverkauft oder zumindest relativ voll. Aber das war es ja auch in den Zweitliga-Jahren, die war es ja als noch sehr, sehr gut besucht, kamen ja regelmäßig über 30.000 und bei besonderen Spielen auch mal über 40.000. Und diese Stimmung, die dann da in dem Fritz-Walter-Stadion ist, die ist bombastisch. Aber für viele Spieler hat das immer auch so ein bisschen belastend irgendwo gewirkt. Und vor allem kann die Stimmung in Kaiserslautern auch sehr schnell kippen, wenn es dann mal nicht läuft. Und dann sucht sich das Publikum in Kaiserslautern auch gerne dann mal den ein oder anderen Schuldigen auf den Platz raus. Und da muss man dann wirklich sagen, der hat dann in den nächsten Wochen keinen Spaß beim Fußballspielen, weil da wird dann teilweise schon gepfiffen, wenn er eingewechselt wird. Und das wirkt einfach belastend auf die Spiele. Ich glaube, das ist eine völlig menschliche Reaktion. Und ich weiß auch, habe ich auch erfahren, dass das auch in Gesprächen mit Neuzugängen teilweise immer mal wieder zum Thema geworden ist. Dass Spieler da gesagt haben, hm, okay. Und quasi so ein bisschen, ja doch, ich sag mal, Respekt vor dieser ganzen Wucht und Dynamik, die dieses Stadion mit ihren Fans auch haben oder annehmen kann hat.
Jetzt muss ich nochmal einen Bogen spannen. Und zwar nochmal einen Bogen zur Ära Atze Friedrich. Ich hab ja gerade eben schon gesagt, schwieriges Umfeld plus eins. Das schwierige Umfeld wird hier in Kaiserslautern auch immer zitiert. An ganz vielen Stellen. Und den Bogen zu Atze Friedrich spann ich deswegen, weil es um eine überzogene Erwartungshaltung im Umfeld geht. Bis heute bei ganz vielen Menschen. Und ich glaube, das rührt unter anderem eben aus dieser Atze Friedrich-Ära her, weil in den Köpfen vieler Leute noch verankert ist, wir sind der große 1. FC Kaiserslautern, wir sind Gründungsmitglied der Bundesliga, wir sind viermaliger deutscher Meister. Wir müssen doch Bundesliga spielen. Und wenn wir dann Bundesliga spielen, dann müssen wir natürlich auch oben mitspielen. Und jetzt hast du eben diese krasse Diskrepanz zwischen dem eigenen Anspruchssenken, Bundesliga und der heutigen Realität, dritte Liga oder zu der Zeit, von der wir jetzt gerade noch sprechen, zweite Liga. Und da ist eben das Problem, dass viele Menschen eine krass überzogene Erwartungshaltung, mittlerweile ist das bei vielen auch angekommen, aber zu der Zeit, über die wir jetzt noch reden, immer noch sehr stark ausgeprägt war, aber eben diese krass überzogene Erwartungshaltung haben und dadurch baut sich ein so unglaublicher Druck ja auch auf die Spieler auf. Das ist ja kein Wunder, dass die sich vielleicht teilweise in die Hose machen oder dass die einfach Angst haben davor oder dass die auch in den Gesprächen, wenn es um neue Verträge geht, fragen, wie ist das hier mit den Fans? Und wir haben es ja auch schon angesprochen, die Stadt ist klein, die Wege sind klein, das heißt, man trifft auch mal des Öfteren die Leute dann in der Stadt, je nachdem, wo man wohnt. Das ist nicht so wie in München, wo dann die Stars in ihrem, wie heißt das, wo die alle wohnen?
Grünwald.
Grünwald, ne? Bei Grünwald und so, da bist du ja mehr oder weniger unter deinesgleichen, aber in Lautern gibt es sowas nicht. Wenn du in Lautern hier irgendwo wohnst, dann triffst du die Leute halt auch und dann wirst du halt auch mal beim Bäcker beschimpft oder angesprochen, was da jetzt los ist. Und dann kriegst du auch mal mit, wie in meinem Fall, wie Kostas Fortunis und seine Mutter sich lauthals auf dem Supermarktparkplatz auf Griechisch streiten. Das kriegst du einfach mit. Das war ein Nachbar von mir, wir haben in derselben Straße gewohnt, deswegen waren wir auch beim selben Supermarkt. Aber was ich damit meine ist, dadurch, dass Kaiserslautern so klein ist, das hat Vorteile, es ist familiär, es hat aber auch Nachteile. Du hast wenig Ausweichmöglichkeiten.
Aber ich finde das...
Das ist eine überzogene, wenn ich ein Wort zu dieser Erwartungshaltung sagen darf, die Sepp gerade angesprochen hat. Zu dem Zeitpunkt über die Jahre, über die wir jetzt reden, ich glaube, wir sind ja jetzt so ungefähr bei den verpassten Bundesliga-Aufstiegen 2013, 2014 so in der Richtung, da war das auf jeden Fall noch so. Heute inzwischen ist es anders. Ich glaube, jeder wird sich inzwischen einfach damit zufriedengeben, wird der FCK in der zweiten Liga gerade spielen. Werder Verein aber dann wieder in der zweiten Liga, dann bin ich mir auch sicher, dass wir dann auch wieder schnell eine Dynamik in diese Erwartungshaltung reinkriegen. Dass es dann wieder heißt, okay, jetzt will ich auch wieder in die Bundesliga.
Und das lässt sich auch ganz leicht zum Beispiel an einem relativ aktuellen Beispiel festmachen. Du hattest vor der Winterpause eine Phase, da hatte der FCK eine Siegesserie hingelegt. Und du merkst immer, sobald der FCK es irgendwie mal schafft, es gab nicht so viele Siegesserien in den letzten Jahren. Aber wenn sowas dann mal passiert, dann wird innerhalb von kurzer Zeit ein Feuer entfacht bei den Fans und beim Umfeld, dass du denkst, hoppla, was ist denn eigentlich hier gerade los? Das heißt, es braucht gar nicht viel, bis dieses Feuer wieder entfacht wird. Und dann ist es auch echt eine Kunst, zu schauen, dass dieses Feuer nicht zu groß wird, sondern dass man die Leute ein bisschen im Zaum hält.
Das ist echt interessant, dass man das bei manchen Vereinen so hat. Und wenn man dann näher in die Historie reinguckt, dann sieht man, so viele erfolgreiche Phasen gab es eigentlich gar nicht, an denen man sich dann immer wieder orientiert. Aber die bleiben eben haften. Bei Lautern war es ja so. Lautern Gründungsmitglied der Bundesliga, haben wir schon gesagt, das lief erstmal so halbwegs in normalen Bahnen, mit einer Ausreißer-Saison, 66, 67. Aber im Grunde so die richtig starke Phase, die war so Ende der 70er, Anfang der 80er, mit Briegel, mit Bremen, Funkel, mit Geye, mit Bongarts.
Du darfst aber eine Sache nicht unterschlagen. Und vor allem musst du auch die Zeit der Vorgründung der Bundesliga noch mit einbeziehen. Klar, wir reden heutzutage über die Bundesliga, aber die 50er Jahre, 51, 53 mit den Meisterschaften, 54 die Weltmeisterschaften mit den 5 Lauter-Weltmeistern, das darfst du nicht vergessen. Da hat das angefangen. Der FCK hat die 50er Jahre dominiert in Fußballdeutschland und auch international in der Nationalmannschaft mit den 5 Lautern. Und da hat das angefangen. Da hat Lautern sich auch unglaublich eine große Reputation aufgebaut.
Ja, völlig richtig. Sehr gut, dass du mich da drauf nochmal hinweist. Weil ich hätte mich jetzt tatsächlich gefragt, woher das kommt. Weil man eben dann, man hatte eben dann Anfang der 80er, Ende der 70er mit den genannten Namen und dann eben wieder, deswegen sind wir ja auch vorhin quasi eingestiegen, man hatte Anfang der 90er die Meisterschaft und eben vor allem dann 1998 dieses, nicht mal einen Abstieg kann uns davon abhalten, nochmal Meister zu werden. Also da fühlst du dich ja auch unbesiegbar. Das kann ich ja auch total nachvollziehen. Also du kommst aus der 2. Liga, bist in der nächsten Saison Meister. Da würde ich mich auch sehr, sehr gut fühlen. Aber das stimmt, die 50er darf man da natürlich nicht vergessen, die Zeit vor der Bundesliga. Dann lasst uns auch, bevor wir jetzt über Weltmeister im Dienst des FCK sprechen, dann lasst uns über das sprechen, was jetzt dann gekommen ist. Wir waren quasi bei der Rückkehr in die 1. Liga 2009, 2010 unter Marco Kurz. Stefan Kunz haben wir jetzt gerade auch schon angesprochen. Aber wir haben ja auch schon angedeutet, und es wird jetzt auch kein Spoiler mehr für die Hörerinnen und Hörer sein. Es sollte leider wieder in die 2. Liga runtergehen. Und das war jetzt dann erstmal der letzte Erstligaaufenthalt. Und der liegt da jetzt dann auch schon 9 Jahre bzw. 8 Jahre, je nachdem, wie gnädig man da zählt, zurück für den 1. FC Kaiserslautern. Kann man sagen, Moritz, dass der verpasste Wiederaufstieg, der ja durchaus knapp war, also einmal in der Relegation gegen Hoffenheim, ich glaube, das war die 1. Saison, 2012, 2013, und dann jeweils mit 4. Plätzen in den Folgejahren, hat sich da so ein bisschen das Schicksal für den FCK dann gedreht. Also so oft ist man letztlich dem Insolvenzverwalter und auch in einem Fall der 3. Liga von der Schippe gesprungen. Aber jetzt geht langsam alles südwärts. Man wird zu einem festen 2. Liga-Teilnehmer, ist jetzt länger in der 2. Liga als in der 1. Liga, wenn man mal so in die Zeit, in die letzten 10 Jahre, dann quasi reinguckt in dieser Phase. Kann man das so einfach sagen oder ist das zu simplifizierend?
Der FCK hat in dieser Phase sehr, sehr viel Pech gehabt. Hätte er, also gerade in diesem Jahr 2012, 2013, du hast die Relegation angesprochen gegen Hoffenheim, da kam ja dazu, dass das Hoffenheim am letzten Spieltag bei Borussia Dortmund gespielt hat. Und ähnlich wie Borussia Dortmund es jetzt diese Woche mit Mainz 05 und letztes Jahr schon mit, oder vor zwei Jahren mit Mainz 05 gemacht hat, haben sie ja jetzt quasi, ähm, ähm, ähm, ähm, soll ich meinen Faden verloren?
Einem Kellerkind zu punkten verholfen.
Einem Kellerkind, genau, einem Kellerkind Aufbauhilfe geleistet, genau. Hoffenheim hat dieses Spiel damals jedenfalls in Dortmund überraschend gewonnen und deswegen hat der FCK in der Relegation gegen Hoffenheim und nicht gegen Fortuna Düsseldorf gespielt. Die Chancen wären gegen Düsseldorf natürlich ganz andere gewesen, weil dieser Kader damals von Hoffenheim, ich glaube sogar Roberto Firminho war damals dabei, hatte in der Relegation natürlich überhaupt nichts verloren. Aber gut, dann ging die Relegation verloren und die folgenden beiden Jahre, wo du jeweils vierter geworden bist, die haben in Kaiserslautern sehr, sehr wehgetan. Du warst bis zum Ende immer, vor allem in der Folgesaison warst du bis zum Schluss ganz vorne dabei. Hast dann, Sepp, korrigier mich, wenn ich jetzt falsch liege, aber hast du nicht dann gegen St. Pauli kurz vor Schluss eines der letzten Heimspiele verloren, das erste Heimspiel in der ganzen Saison, was dich dann quasi so ein bisschen von deinen Aufstiegsdräumen entfernt hat. Und am Ende bist du vierter. Das war viel frech dabei, ja. Und das mit einer Mannschaft, die wirklich, also auch im Jahr darauf, mit hochtalentierten Spielern, Kerim Demirbay ist vorhin angesprochen worden, Kevin Stöger, Jean Zimmer, alles Bundesligaspieler heute. Und Stefan Kuhns hat in dieser Zeit sportlich sicher nicht alles richtig gemacht, hat vor allem eine, muss man doch sagen, teilweise wahnsinnige Transferstrategie gefahren, weil in den acht Kuhns Spielzeiten von 2008, 2009 bis 2015, 2016 hat er insgesamt 120 externe Neuzugänge zum FCK geholt, dazu noch 25 Spieler aus dem Nachwuchs. Das heißt, wir reden von 150 Neuzugängen in acht Jahren.
Jetzt stelle man sich mal vor, er hätte verdient bei Spielerwechseln, meine Güte. Das hätte man wahrscheinlich auch gemerkt, weil er seine Zähne durch Diamanten ersetzt hätte.
Das heißt, diese Fluktuation im Kader, da konnte sich nie so richtig was einspielen. Und trotzdem, weil du doch so gute Einzelspieler drin gehabt hast, hätte es fast geklappt. Und wenn du in einem dieser Jahre den Aufstieg wieder geschafft hättest, dann hätte es ja auch finanziell ganz anders ausgesehen. Aber diese Zweitliga-Jahre, erst recht dieser Abstieg, und wir müssen bei dem Jahr 2013 natürlich eine große, dicke Nadel setzen, was die Finanzen angeht. Weil da hat der FCK seine erste Fananleihe ausgegeben, hat damals 6 Millionen Euro eingenommen. Und genau diese 6 Millionen Euro wurden eben im letzten Jahr halt zum Verhängnis. Und das letzte Jahr hat quasi zu diesem Jahr geführt und zur Insolvenz. Aber darin seht ihr ja auch wieder, das Geld war einfach nicht da. Und mit diesen 6 Millionen hat sich der FCK wieder Luft verschafft. Aber letztendlich blieb der sportliche Erfolg aus.
Da sind wir wieder bei diesem Aufkante genäht, was wir vorhin schon mal hatten und bei diesem unbedingt mitspielen wollen. Es ist halt einfach auch, es hat ja was von Pokern. Weil du gehst ein Risiko ein und es hätte ja zum Beispiel auch einmal, es war ja mehrfach knapp, es hätte ja auch mal gut gehen können und man hätte einmal wieder aufsteigen können. Und schwuppdiwupp hättest du wieder, selbst wenn du dann irgendwann wieder absteigst, hättest du aber zumindest wieder mindestens ein Jahr so gute Einnahmen gehabt, um dir da wieder ein bisschen ein Kreuze zu verschaffen. Weil es ist einfach so, das muss man ja auch mal sehen, der Unterschied, die Differenz zwischen den Einnahmen in der ersten Liga und der zweiten Liga ist schon groß. Jetzt spielt der FCK die dritte Liga, das sind Welten, das sind wirklich Welten.
Da kannst du im Grunde deine, also wenn du von der zweiten in die dritte Liga absteigst, dann kannst du deine komplette Planung, deine Finanzplanung eigentlich völlig neu aufsetzen und zwischen zweiter und erster ist schon eine deutliche Reduzierung.
Es kann in der dritten Liga auch, da kommen wir ja gleich noch zu, da will ich jetzt nicht so viel vorwegnehmen, aber da kann meiner Meinung nach auch kein Verein vernünftig wirtschaften. Also wie soll das gehen? Das ist ein viel zitiertes Millionengrab.
Die Millionengräber und die Leichen im Keller, das wären so ein bisschen unsere Analogien. Einmal ist es das Stadion, einmal die Liga und dann natürlich die schon vorhin angesprochenen Leichen im Keller. Aber lass noch kurz bei dieser 2013er Fan-Anleihe bleiben. Moritz, du hast schon gesagt, da müssen wir eine dicke Nadel einstechen. Also man hat diese Fan-Anleihe gebraucht, weil durch die Zweitligazugehörigkeit und gleichzeitig hohen Fixkosten unter anderem das Stadion in einer schlechten liquiden Lage war. Jetzt habe ich das aber so nachgelesen und mich auch noch so grob erinnert, dass die Fan-Anleihe ja aber eigentlich zweckgebunden war. Und zwar nicht zur Deckelung von laufenden Ausgaben gedacht war, sondern als Investitionssumme in eben Dinge wie Infrastruktur rund um Nachwuchs. Ich weiß nicht, ob es auch um das Nachwuchsleistungszentrum an sich ging, aber zumindest sollte damit eigentlich investiert werden. Und dann im Nachhinein hat sich rausgestellt, so ganz hat sich da der Verein aber nicht dran gehalten. Wie ist es denn jetzt? Also habe ich das jetzt so richtig zusammengefasst?
Das hast du grob richtig zusammengefasst. Diese Anleihe war prinzipiell zweckgebunden. Was dem Verein aber natürlich auch, selbst wenn sie zu 100% zweckgebunden eingesetzt worden wäre, hätte es ihm im sportlichen Bereich ja geholfen, weil du ja quasi die andere Liquidität, die dir zur Verfügung steht, eben dann komplett im Tagesgeschäft, sage ich mal, verbraten kannst und davon nichts mehr ins Nachwuchsleistungszentrum oder Ähnliches stecken. Genau, aber was mit dieser Anleihe dann tatsächlich passiert ist, da gibt es bis heute auch noch viele Diskussionen drüber.
Was ist das denn wieder, was man nicht weiß? Wie kann denn das sein, dass man immer alles nicht weiß?
Stefan Kuhns hat, als er zu Beginn des Jahres 2016 gegangen ist, behauptet oder gesagt, es wären noch 2 Millionen aus dieser Fan-Anleihe vorhanden, die nicht ausgegeben worden wären. Michael Klatt, der auf ihn gefolgt ist. Hat auf einer seiner legendären Sätze gesagt, er ist in den Keller gegangen und hat da eben nichts mehr gefunden.
Stimmt, das habe ich auch irgendwann mal gehört. Da gab es ein Zitat, wir haben wirklich auf allen Konten geguckt, das Geld ist nicht mehr da. Und das ist schon wirklich sehr alarmierend, wenn jemand von deinem Verein das sagt.
Genau, und daraus lässt sich fließen und das ist jetzt auch kein ganz großes Geheimnis. Diese 2 Millionen Euro sind einfach im Tagesgeschäft untergegangen, weil du sie für die Liquidität gebraucht hast.
Ich meine, grundsätzlich ist es ja so, wenn ich jetzt einen Zweitligisten führen würde und ich habe Geld bekommen und habe gleichzeitig ganz große Finanzierungsprobleme, dann ist es nicht nur logisch nachvollziehbar, sondern dann kann man das sogar auch juristisch rechtfertigen. Man ist ja tatsächlich als Geschäftsführer da dann auch in einer Verantwortung dem Verein gegenüber, dass man das so einsetzt. Aber ich habe das Gefühl, dass hier jetzt insofern eine Grenze überschritten wurde, weil bei den ganzen Leichen im Keller, die wir vorhin thematisiert haben, da wurden andere übers Ohr gehauen, nämlich das Finanzamt oder die Branche, um das mal so zu sagen. Aber jetzt hat man ja tatsächlich das Wort gebrochen, dass man den Fans gegeben hat. Denen hat man doch gesagt, wir setzen das für die Nachwuchsleistung ein, und das hat man letztlich nicht getan.
Genau. Und genau das ist das Problem. Es ist das eine, ob du irgendetwas rechtlich darfst, weil es irgendwo im Kleingedruckten steht. Und es ist das andere, ob du es dann wirklich durchziehst, obwohl du es nach außen hin anders verkauft hast. Und du hast es nun mal, oder die Vereinsführung damals hat es nun mal so verkauft, dass dieses Geld vor allem in das Nachwuchsleistungszentrum fließen soll. Und das ist es nicht. Das ist auch ein Punkt, ich habe es ja vorhin schon angesprochen, warum das Nachwuchsleistungszentrum eben nicht so aussieht, wie man sich das vielleicht wünschen würde. Und das hat natürlich zu einem großen Bruch mit den Fans gesorgt. Und trotzdem kaufen die Fans heute, haben sie später raus, noch eine zweite Anleihe gekauft, würden wahrscheinlich gezeichnet, würden wahrscheinlich noch eine dritte zeichnen, weil sie einfach dem Verein unglaublich treu sind. Man sieht, du siehst ja jetzt auch anhand unseres Gesprächs, was die Fans alles schon durchmachen mussten. Und trotzdem halten sie ihrem Verein die Stange, trotz aller Widrigkeiten. Das ist schon bemerkenswert. Aber das hat tatsächlich zu einem spürbaren Bruch geführt, definitiv.
Es ging halt auch einfach um diesen Vertrauensverlust, der gerade angesprochen worden ist durch diesen Bruch. Weil justiziabel konnte man ihm überhaupt nichts nachweisen, sage ich jetzt mal, weil die Fananleihe war zwar ansichtswegebunden, aber es war nirgendwo juristisch festgelegt, dass sie wirklich nur da investiert werden darf. Und gewissermaßen wurde das auch, ich glaube, das hat Stefan Kuhns oder Michael Glatt mal erklärt, weiß ich nicht. Aber die Geldflüsse bei einem Fußballverein, die sind ja nicht kontinuierlich gleich, sondern es gibt ja immer wieder Liquiditätshöhen und Liquiditätszähler. Gerade am Anfang des Jahres zu Beginn einer Saison, wenn alle Dauerkarteninhaber ihr Geld überweisen, kommt natürlich da wieder mehr Geld rein. Die Sponsoren überweisen zu gewissen Zeiten. Und um die sogenannten Liquiditätszähler, wo eben gerade kein Geld reinkommt, zu überbrücken, dafür nimmt man dann natürlich auch eine Fähnerleihe zur Hand. Weil diese Fähnerleihe, diese 2 Millionen Euro, die auf dem Konto liegen, da steht ja nicht im Konto drauf Nachwuchsleistungszentrum, sondern die liegen ja auf dem Konto wie jeder andere Euro auch. Und natürlich kann der dafür auch benutzt werden, völlig legitim. Macht niemand anders. Nur sollte halt irgendwann auch wieder das Liquiditätshochkommen und die 2 Millionen Euro auf der hohen Kante liegen fürs Nachwuchsleistungszentrum. Nur dieser Fall ist eben nie eingetreten.
Da sind wir wieder beim Stichwort Pokern. Dann macht man sowas wahrscheinlich in der Annahme, ja Mensch, gut, wir nehmen das jetzt mal. Es wird schon irgendwann wieder Geld kommen. Es wird schon wieder laufen. Wir werden wieder Erfolg haben oder wir werden wieder irgendeinen Spieler verkaufen können für ein paar Millionen. Und dann hätte wahrscheinlich kein Hahn danach gekräht. Aber dieses Pokerspiel ist halt leider nicht so ganz aufgegangen.
Und da kommt ja dann auch wieder die sportliche Komponente ins Spiel. Also die 6 Zweitligaspielzeiten, beginnend mit 2012, 2013, teilen sich wie das Meer vor Moses. Einmal die ersten 3 Jahre, knapp am Ausstieg vorbeigeschrammt, haben wir gerade thematisiert. Und dann die zweiten 3 Jahre, wo es dann immer, immer näher Richtung Abstieg in die 3. Liga ging, was dann letztlich auch erfolgt ist. Und mittendrin endet auch die Ära von Steffen Kunz, die man deshalb auch Ära nennen kann, weil ich ja vorhin schon rausgearbeitet habe. Er ist bemerkenswert lange geblieben dafür, im Vergleich zu seinen sonstigen Kollegen beim 1. FC Kaiserslautern. Und da setzt er jetzt auch eine Phase ein. Also ab jetzt hört es bei mir bei den Namen ganz schnell auf, weil es einfach auch jetzt eine krasse Rotation ist, nicht nur auf dem Trainerposten. Aber jetzt kommen auch Namen zum 1. FC Kaiserslautern, die für mich dann auch gar nicht immer noch was mit Fußball zu tun hatten. Also Uwe Stöver als Sportdirektor ist schiefgegangen. Kann man das so zusammenfassen, Moritz, dass in dieser Phase beim 1. FC K auch die Fußballkompetenz nicht immer zumindest die allerhöchste, allergrößte war auf entscheidende Positionen?
Ich glaube, das ist noch sehr freundlich ausgedrückt von dir.
Ich habe extra versucht, diplomatisch zu sein.
Ja, ich glaube, die Diplomatie brauchen wir an dieser Stelle gerade mal nicht. Du hattest Stefan Kuhns. Und ich glaube, über die fußballerischen Fähigkeiten und auch auf den Managementpositionen im Fußball von Stefan Kuhns, die Expertise, ich glaube, darüber brauchen wir uns nicht unterhalten in dem Punkt. Ich glaube, wir haben eine sehr gute Beziehung, eine gute Unternehmensberatung, BWL in diese Richtung. Hatte aber, und das muss man einfach sagen, mit Fußballvereinen vorher überhaupt nichts am Hut. Und der Plan war ja ursprünglich auch, dass die beiden zusammen mit Stefan Kuhns den Verein weiterführen, in einer Dreier-Spitze. Aber dann hat man sich mit Stefan Kuhns überworfen und Stefan Kuhns ist zurückgetreten. Das heißt, die beiden waren auf einmal alleine und hatten keine sportliche Expertise an der Hand. Beziehungsweise nicht auf höchster Ebene im Verein. Und genau das war einfach das Problem. Es sind fatale Entscheidungen in sämtlichen Bereichen getroffen worden. Uwe Stöver, der ja dann als Sportdirektor geholt worden ist, der wäre auch gerne Vorstand geworden. Den Posten hat man ihm aber nicht gegeben. Und dann dreht sich das auch immer wieder weiter.
Der Philipp Lahm des 1.
Der Philipp Lahm des 1. FC Kaiserslautern, obwohl ich eigentlich die nahen Uwe Stöver und Philipp Lahm schwierig in einem Atemzug nehme.
Das ist ein ganz komischer Vergleich.
Und du bist dann auf diesen Sommer vor der Saison 2016, 2017 ja etwas zugeschlittert. Dann hast du Typhoon Korkut im Sommer als Trainer geholt und hast Uwe Stöver als Sportdirektor gehabt. Und was in diesem Sommer sowohl sportlich als auch wirtschaftlich an Entscheidungen getroffen worden ist, da sträuben sich mir heute noch die Haare. Der FCK, wenn ich kurz ausholen darf, der FCK wäre mit einem Budget von 8 Millionen Euro, das war damals Zweitligadurchschnitt in etwa, in die Saison gegangen und hätte damit eine Rolle spielen können im Mittelfeld, hätte vielleicht überraschen können, wie auch immer. Uwe Stöver wollte aber unbedingt noch mehr Geld, wollte noch mehr Geld in den Kader investieren, wollte neue Spieler holen. Michael Glatt hat ihm dann, was damals viele verwundert hat, weil Michael Glatt eigentlich ihm wurde eine Nicht-Schulden-Machen-Politik nachgesagt. Er hatte ja auch zu Beginn den Plan, also er hatte ja auch den Plan, den Verein zu sanieren. Gut, er konnte überhaupt keinen anderen Plan haben. Aber letztendlich hat er den sportlichen Wünschen von Thaif und Korkut und Uwe Stöver nachgegeben und hat ein Darlehen über 3 Millionen Euro bei, ratet mal, Quatrex aufgenommen. Und jetzt kommen wir zu Quatrex. Und dieses 3 Millionen Euro Darlehen wurde komplett in die Mannschaft gesteckt. Der Etat wurde quasi von 8 Millionen auf 11 Millionen Euro erhöht. Und die FC K Fans werden bei den Namen jetzt mit dem Kopf schütteln. Unter anderem ist von diesem Geld Zoltan Stieber geholt worden. Es ist Mensur Muiça, wenn euch der Name noch was sagt, vom SC Freiburg. Der ist geholt worden, hat kein Spiel gemacht und war danach sportinvalide. Und diese ganzen Entscheidungen, dieses Geld, Jacques Suá, der Stürmer, dürfen wir auch nicht vergessen. Diese 3 Millionen Euro, die sind so was von innen Sand gesetzt worden. Das heißt, sie haben dich wirklich kein Stückchen weitergebracht. Geschweige dessen, sie haben dich zurückgeworfen. Du bist ja eine Tabelle im nächsten Jahr noch weiter abgestürzt. Das heißt, die ganzen internen Streitigkeiten, Typhoon Corcourt ist ja auch damals im Dezember zurückgetreten nach nicht mal einem halben Jahr in Kaiserslautern. Dieses ganze Konstrukt, dann ging es im Winter weiter mit Personen aus dem Aufsichtsrat, die sich einen Platz im sportlichen Bereich sichern wollten, und so weiter und so fort. Der Verein hat sich innerlich zerlegt damals.
Das ist eine ziemlich heftige Analyse, wie kritisch. Sebastian, wurde das damals gesehen, dass da jemand wie Quatrex mit reinkam? Mir persönlich geht es so, dass ich jetzt ein Wissen über Quattrix habe. Das hätte ich nicht. Ich hab sie nicht richtig, aber 2016 noch nicht gehabt. So ehrlich will ich sein. Wie kritisch wurde das denn damals begleitet?
Ich glaube, so wie dir ging es damals den meisten. Das wurde nicht besonders kritisch begleitet. Das wurde von der Öffentlichkeit auch gar nicht so krass wahrgenommen, wie es heute wahrgenommen wird. Weil viele das auch, glaube ich, gar nicht wussten, dass das der Fall war. Und ich glaube, zu dem damaligen Zeitpunkt haben sich einfach auch viele gewünscht, egal wo das Geld jetzt herkommt, ich meine, wünschen sie sich heute immer noch, aber egal wo es herkommt, wir nehmen das und versuchen damit sportlich wieder anzugreifen. Aber die wirklich große Kritik an dem Ganzen, die kam erst später.
Wohl auch damals natürlich, als dann rausgekommen ist, zu welchen Konditionen dieses Darlehen vergeben worden ist, gab es damals schon sehr kritische Stimmen. Man muss auch sagen, wir haben damals nicht nur von einem 3 Millionen Euro Darlehen gesprochen, sondern wir haben von einem größeren Paket, ich meine von 8 Millionen Euro, gesprochen, dass der FCK innerhalb eines gewissen Zeitraums abrufen kann, was er in der Folge auch getan hat. Aber es ist eben nur mit diesem 3 Millionen Euro Darlehen gestartet. Aber ich habe es ja vorhin schon angesprochen, 7,5 Prozent Zinsen plus erfolgsabhängige Bonuszahlungen. Diese erfolgsabhängigen Bonuszahlungen, die haben es richtig in sich. Die hat der FCK natürlich nie zahlen müssen, weil er nie sportlichen Erfolg hatte. Aber die sind an die Fernsehgelder, an die TV-Einnahmen gekoppelt gewesen. Und zwar sind die direkt an den Anstieg der TV-Einnahmen gekoppelt gewesen. Das heißt, wäre der FCK aufgestiegen, die Fernsehgelder explodieren ja. In der zweiten Liga gibt es dieses Jahr im Schnitt circa 12 Millionen Fernsehgelder. Und in der ersten Liga bist du mal ganz schnell bei 30 Millionen Euro Fernsehgeldern. Und genau an diesem Anstieg, von diesem Anstieg hätte Quatrix profitiert. Übrigens, Quatrix ist ja auch bei Union Berlin im Hut. Und der Aufstieg von Union Berlin hat Quatrix sehr viel Geld gebracht, weil die Bedingungen sind dort ähnlich.
Man muss sich ja auch noch mal verdeutlichen, dass alles hat ja parallel zu Einsparmaßnahmen auch stattgefunden. Also man hat ja auf der Geschäftsstelle Personal abgebaut. Der Herr Klatt hat da den Rotstift angesetzt und hat gespart, wo es nur ging. Auf der anderen Seite gehst du dann solche Deals ein, die einfach, und da komme ich wieder zu dem Punkt, die einfach eine sehr große Wette sind. Du setzt einfach auf ein Pferd und in dem Fall auf das Falsche.
Ja, vor allem selbst wenn die Wette aufgegangen wäre, würde ich mal infrage stellen, wie nachhaltig das alles kalkuliert war. Wenn du quasi auf, also du pokerst mit geliehenem Geld und versprichst dann aber jemandem, demjenigen, der dir das Geld geliehen hat, auch einen Anteil an deinem Gewinn. Gleichzeitig befinden wir uns jetzt ja auch schon in der Phase, in der ja auch die Stadt Kaiserslautern immer wieder auf den Verein zugekommen ist und gesagt hat, also gut hier, Stadion, Miete, da machen wir jetzt noch mal, tun wir jetzt einfach mal so, wenn es euch besser geht, dann könnt ihr ja vielleicht noch zahlen. Also man ist ja eigentlich schon in so einer Phase, in der viele Leute von einem Geld wollen, in dem man eigentlich kein Geld hat, dann leiht man sich Geld und weiß aber, im Fall eines Erfolges kann ich jetzt nicht nur irgendwie alle anderen bedienen, sondern ein Teil des Gewinns geht dann gleich sofort an den, der es mir geliehen hat. Also selbst wenn Lautern jetzt in dieser Phase aufgestiegen wäre, kann ich mir jetzt eigentlich gerade kein Szenario ausmalen, außer man wäre irgendwie wie durch ein Wunder jetzt dann 2-3 Jahre in der 1. Liga geblieben, in dem das nachhaltig gewesen wäre.
Das ist ja das ganz große Problem beim FCK. Es wurde nie wirklich ein nachhaltiges Konzept ausgearbeitet, sondern das waren immer kurzfristige Geschichten. Es wurde immer geschaut, wie können wir kurzfristig Erfolg haben? Wie können wir jetzt innerhalb des nächsten Jahres sportlichen Erfolg haben? Wie können wir es schaffen, jetzt dann doch eben wieder aufzusteigen? Aber es hat sich, glaube ich, kaum jemand wirklich Gedanken darüber gemacht, wie man diesen Verein nachhaltig auf gesunde Beine stellen kann. Das passiert alles erst jetzt. Das ist ja das ganz, ganz große Problem.
Wie kritisch diese Lage im Jahr 2016-17 trotz dieses Quadtrex-Kritiz am Anfang und diese 3,5 Millionen Euro, die komplett in den Kader gesteckt worden sind. 3 Vierteljahr später war die Lage wieder so kritisch, dass der FCK damals ging es um den Transfer Jean Zimmer zum VfB Stuttgart, dass der FCK quasi dem VfB Stuttgart einen doch beachtlichen Teil der Transfersumme erlassen hat, wenn der VfB bitte zwei Monate früher überweist.
Also auch für andere Vereine, das muss man ja auch mal wirklich sagen, war, glaube ich, ist echt eine ganz nette Sache mit dem FCK solche Deals zu machen, weil man sicherlich den einen oder anderen Spieler zu einem deutlich besseren Preis bekommen hat, als wenn der FCK jetzt in einer besseren Verhandlungsposition gewesen wäre. Weil ja schon immer alle Konkurrenten wissen, ja gut, der FCK braucht das Geld, also können wir pokern und können sagen, ja gut, ihr braucht es jetzt, aber wir zahlen dann eben nicht den Marktwert, sondern wir bleiben drunter.
Ja klar, das ist ja auch logisch. Und sportlich sah die Lage so aus, also in der Saison 15, 16, also gerade noch, also 10. Platz, das war noch halbwegs in Ordnung, und dann eben 16, 17, die eben jetzt angesprochene Saison, mit der kurzen, mit dem Ehrchen, kann man Ära diminuieren? Na ja, es war keine Ära von Taif und Korkut, und danach kam eben Norbert Maier, der auch nicht arg lange Trainer sein sollte beim 1. FC Kaiserslautern. Da hat man es dann immerhin geschafft, mit 29 geschossenen Toren noch 13. zu werden, also man kann da auch noch was Positives rausziehen aus der Saison, aber das war schon ganz schön, naja, ist das auch eine Leistung, aber das war eben schon ganz schön knapp, also deswegen habe ich die erzielten Tore dazu genannt, man hatte immerhin eine ganz gute Abwehr mit nur 33 Gegentreffen, aber deswegen war das Platz 13 und dann kam ja 2017, 2018 der Abstieg, auch ein knallender Abstieg mit Platz 18, neun Siege in der ganzen Saison, das ging sehr, sehr schnell da Richtung dritte Liga und da kommt jetzt aber noch ein Name mit rein, wenn wir eben Teil von Korkut und Norbert Meyer schon nennen, der aber eben auch wichtig ist und der aber eine ganz andere Note noch mal mit reinbringt, nämlich Jeff Strasser. Was ist zu ihm zu sagen und seine Zeit bei Lautern, Sebastian?
Na, das war natürlich sehr tragisch, weil Jeff Strasser hat als Person sehr, sehr gut zum FCK gepasst, weil sich die Menschen in Kaiserslautern und wahrscheinlich bei vielen anderen Vereinen auch, vor allem bei den Traditionsvereinen, Protagonisten mit dem viel zitierten Stahlgeruch wünschen. Das heißt, sie wünschen sich Menschen, die eine Vorgeschichte haben, die eine Vereinsvergangenheit haben, die Jeff Strasser hat, weil er war ja auch Spieler beim FCK. Und er war zwar auch, sag ich mal, nicht der begnadeste Techniker, aber er war einfach jemand, der für sehr ehrlichen Fußball gestanden hat und für Einsatz. Und genau das ist ja das, was die Menschen in Kaiserslautern schon seit jeher sehen wollen. Die Leute wollen da und erwarten da keinen technisch feinen Fußball, sondern es geht um Einsatz. Es geht darum, dass man auch in der 94. Minute noch einen Sprint anzieht und noch eine Gräte ansetzt. Und genau deswegen hat das sehr gut gepasst, weil Jeff Strasser von der Art her einfach sehr, sehr gut zum FCK gepasst hat. Und dann gab es ja einfach diesen tragischen Vorfall, wo er aufgrund einer Herzmuskelentzündung während eines Spiels quasi ausgefallen ist und dann im Nachhinein ihm das auch den Job gekostet hat.
Genau, bzw. er konnte dann eben quasi aus gesundheitlichen Gründen nicht weitermachen.
Genau, er konnte aus gesundheitlichen Gründen nicht weitermachen und der Verein musste dann reagieren und hat dann eben nachverpflichtet sozusagen. Aber wir haben einen Sprung gemacht. Ich dachte nämlich eigentlich, dass du noch einen anderen Namen mit reinbringst, nämlich Martin Bader.
Ah ja, um Gottes Willen, natürlich.
Der hat mich auch noch krank.
Logisch, logisch. Ja, richtig.
Auch keine ganz unwichtige Personalien, weil man hat sich dann irgendwann gedacht, okay, wir holen uns jetzt noch sportliche Kompetenz in die Vereinsführung und verpflichten Martin Bader als Sport-Forschlankt.
Ist ja mal ganz erfrischend nach dem, was wir vorher erlebt hatten, jetzt wieder sportliche Kompetenz, cool.
Ja, nur das hat halt auch nur so semi gut geklappt, nicht wahr, Moritz?
Martin Bader, damals ja quasi zeitgleich mit dem Nachfolger Chef Strasser ist gekommen. Aber ich sag mal, Chef Strasser hatte ja im Dezember schon ein Himmelfahrtskommando übernommen in der Hinrunde, weil das, was Norbert Meyer mit der Mannschaft in den ersten 7, 8 Spieltagen, ich glaube, waren es nicht nach 8 Spieltagen, 7 Niederlagen oder so was, sowas in die Richtung auf jeden Fall, das war schon sehr abstiegswürdig. Die Mannschaft hatte halt auch das Problem, und das muss man auch tatsächlich Norbert Meyer zugute heißen. Norbert Meyer hat intern vor der Saison gesagt, wenn ich die Spieler Robin Koch verliere und Everton, dann wird es ganz, ganz eng. Robin Koch damals und Everton damals die Innenverteidigung gebildet, Robin Koch heute in Freiburg Stammspieler, Bundesliga-Nationalspieler. Everton wäre nicht von seinem Verletzungspech geplagt, sicherlich Stammspieler beim Hamburger SV. Und auf jeden Fall auch das Potenzial für Bundesliga, was er ja mit dem 1. FC Nürnberg auch schon gespielt hat. Und diese beiden Spieler mussten aber eben, bzw. Robin Koch musste verkauft werden für 4 Millionen Euro, um zu überleben. Und Everton konnte nicht ein weiteres Jahr ausgeliehen werden.
Und Paulas Beck ist ja auch noch gewechselt in diesen...
Paulas Beck ist auch noch gewechselt, obwohl man da ja mit dem ausgeliehenen Marius Müller von RB Leipzig einen adäquaten Ersatz hatte.
Wobei Paulas Beck ja auch wieder finanzielle Aspekte hatte.
Natürlich, 3,5 Millionen Euro Ablöse damals gebracht auch. Du steigst fast aus der zweiten Liga ab oder bis zumindest im unteren Drittel und sammelst mal 7,5 Millionen mit zwei Spielern ein. Das kann auch nicht jeder von sich behaupten.
Ja, es tut mir leid. Es ist aber auch einfach wirklich bizarr. Es war ja schon in der Vorbereitung bizarr, aber ihr eröffnet mir hier noch mal ganz neue Absurditätslevel.
Aber gut. Aber gut, wir waren bei Martin Bader angelangt. Der FCK hat sich Anfang Februar 2018 wieder sportliche Kompetenz ins Boot holen wollen und hat Martin Bader gewählt. Er hatte natürlich einen sehr unangenehmen Start, das muss man wirklich sagen, weil Martin Bader ist gekommen und hat sofort einen neuen Trainer verpflichten müssen, weil die Erkrankung von Jeff Strasser eine Fortführung des Trainer-Jobs in dieser Saison nicht mehr ermöglicht hat. Da hat er dann an seinen alten Freund Michael Fronsek aus Hanoverer Zeiten gedacht. Ob sie wirklich befreundet sind, das weiß ich gar nicht. Aber Michael Fronsek, was fällt dir so direkt zu Michael Fronsek ein? Wir müssen ihm zugute heißen, diese Rückrunde, in der der FCK eigentlich aussichtslos abgestiegen war, hat er doch noch relativ viele Punkte geholt. Auch ich bin damals mit Beginn der neuen Saison in die neue Saison reingegangen, mit dem Gedanken, okay, könnte vielleicht der Richtige sein.
Ja, den Eindruck hatte ich eigentlich auch. Ich hatte anfangs auch schon den Eindruck, dass er die Mannschaft erreicht. Aber je länger dieses Engagement gedauert hat, desto mehr habe ich diese Überzeugung verloren. Und auch die Art und Weise der Kommunikation ist ein schönes Beispiel. Da traf es unter anderem auch mal deinen guten Kollegen Carsten Schröder-Lorens vom Kicker, der dann, sage ich mal, mitbekommen hat in einer Pressekonferenz, wie das ist, wenn Herr Fronsek nicht gut auf einen zu sprechen ist. Da wurde dann gerne mal öffentlich in der Pressekonferenzrunde gegen einen kritischen Artikel gewettert und quasi ganz deutlich gemacht, dass man mit diesen Leuten oder mit demjenigen, der den Artikel geschrieben hat, nicht mehr sprechen will. Also er war einfach auch eine schwierige Persönlichkeit. Und ich glaube, wenn da einmal irgendwas vorgefallen ist, was ihm gefallen hat, dann war man durch bei Michael Fronsek oder ist es wahrscheinlich immer noch.
Genau. Und das, was du jetzt gerade angesprochen hast, das war ja dann schon nach dem Abstieg. Also das war ja dann schon wieder auf dem absteigenden Ast in der dritten Liga, weil dieses ganze... Er hat den Fehmel übernommen. Er hat da auch profitiert von der Arbeit Chef Strassers, weil Chef Strasser es geschafft hat, diese Mannschaft in der Wintervorbereitung körperlich wirklich topfit zu machen. Weil das einer der großen Punkte, die Norbert Meyer verpasst hat. Die Mannschaft war nicht fit. Und da hat Chef Strasser in der Winterpause angesetzt und es ist ihm wirklich gelungen. Und davon hat Michael Fronsek natürlich auch extrem profitiert, weil er eine topfitte Mannschaft übernehmen konnte.
Und das ist ja glaube ich der Ausgangspunkt, warum Chef Strasser dann die Herzmuskelentzündung hatte. Weil er eben so akribisch gearbeitet hat und sich selber nicht geschont hat in dieser Vorbereitung. Obwohl er erkältet war zu der Zeit. Das müsste in der Hintergrund gewesen sein. Sorry, ich habe dich unterbrochen.
Genau, es war eigentlich dann eine sehr erfolgreiche Rückrunde. Also kurz um es zu illustrieren, in der Hinrunde zwei Siege, fünf Unentschieden, elf Punkte. In der Rückrunde sieben Siege, drei Unentschieden, 24 Punkte. Also man hat ein Vielfaches der Punkte geholt, aber es sollte eben dann trotzdem nicht zu mehr reichen als den letzten Platz in der zweiten Liga. Aber das war eben dann Michael Fronzig aufbauen auf dem, was der Chef Strasser dahingestellt hat. Und was ist dann in der Folge passiert, Moritz?
Nach dem Abstieg hat sich in Kaiserslautern eine Euphorie entwickelt, wie sie sich, glaube ich, noch bei keinem anderen Verein auf diesem Welt nach einem Abstieg entwickelt hat. Also ich habe mich da selbst auch ab und zu mal umgucken müssen und habe gedacht, passiert das hier gerade alles wirklich? Also das erste Training damals in der Sommervorbereitung für die Saison 2018-19, der ersten Drittligasaison des FC Kaiserslauterns. Ich glaube, es waren, Sebastian, mehrere Tausend Leute beim Auftakttraining. Da war eine Stimmung. Jeder war sich sicher, OK, ein Jahr dritte Liga, nehmen wir zum Neuanfang. Wir steigen wieder auf und dann wird alles wieder gut.
Das war ähnlich, wie damals nach dem ersten Abstieg in die zweite Liga. Da gab es diese Euphorie auch.
Und die Erwartungshaltung, das muss man wirklich sagen, die war aber halt bei allen Fans auch dritte Liga. Wir sind der große FCK, hier marschieren wir jetzt mal durch. Und ich glaube, dass sich dieses Bild auch in den Köpfen der Spieler irgendwo verankert hat. Weil in dem Sommer sind viele neue Spieler gekommen, die vorher auch schon bei Drittligisten unter Vertrag gestanden haben. Und natürlich macht es einen großen, großen Unterschied, ob du bei den Würzburger Kickers, ob du bei Kai Sajsiena oder Sonnenhof Groß-Aßbach, um es einfach mal drei Mannschaften zu nennen, spielst oder beim FCK in der dritten Liga. Das Anspruchsdenken und deine Ziele sind ja natürlich ganz, ganz andere. Und dadurch, dass auch diese Erwartungshaltung von außen so an die Mannschaft herangetragen worden ist. Und wenn du anfängst zu trainieren in der dritten Liga und du hast 3.000 Leute beim Auftakttraining, die du in Groß-Aßbach nicht mal bei zwei Heimspielen zusammen hast, ah ja klar, da weißt du auch, der Weg kann eigentlich nur der Aufstieg sein. Nur dazu ist es ja eben nicht gekommen.
Das kann ich auch nur unterstreichen. Ich war damals im Trainingslager auch mit dabei. Und diese Euphorie, ich konnte mir das gar nicht erklären. Es war für alle vollkommen klar, das war jetzt ein Ausrutscher. Aber genau wie es Moritz gesagt hat, wir sind der große FCK, wir maschinen da jetzt durch. Das hatte so ein bisschen Urlaubsfeeling, es war gutes Wetter. Und der FCK war dann auch in der Region tatsächlich im Trainingslager, in Herxheim einer, das was wirklich nicht weit weg ist von Kaiserslautern. Und es kamen Massen zu diesen Trainingseinheiten, es war wirklich Wahnsinn. Und es ist wirklich auf heutiger Sicht sogar noch weniger nachzuvollziehen, woher diese Euphorie kam. Und das ist einfach, man kann das nicht erklären, was das ist beim FCK, aber irgendwie schafft das eben doch immer wieder, diesen Funken irgendwie, dieses Feuer zu entfachen bei den Fans, als wenn er absteigt in die dritte Liga.
Naja, also ich hab das ja hier in München mit 1860 erlebt und ich glaube auch da gibt es eine Parallele zu 1860. Es kann auch eine Befreiung sein, wenn es dich dann endlich mal erwischt hat. Und wenn quasi dieses Rumkrebsen und bis zum letzten Spieltag hoffen, wenn das weg ist und wenn du im Gegenteil das Gefühl hast, jetzt sind wir in der Liga, da können wir wieder mithalten. Wir gewinnen jetzt wieder Spiele, wir gehen mit einer ganz anderen Haltung hin, wir machen da jetzt ein Riesenevent draus, die werden sich alle umschauen, wie viele Zuschauer jetzt trotzdem noch kommen. Jetzt können jeder einzelne, der jetzt ins Stadion geht, der geht da nicht hin, um zu hoffen, dass man irgendwie 1 zu 0 in der 93. Minute gewinnt, sondern er geht da erstmal hin, um zu zeigen, hier, ich komme auch in der dritten Liga, mein Verein könnte mir nicht wegnehmen. Also ich kann das schon sehr gut nachvollziehen. Gleichzeitig ist es interessant, dass ja da zwei Dinge jetzt dann trotzdem noch parallel passieren. Also dieses ideelle, das ist ja was Tolles, das zeigt ja auch, warum der Fußball dann doch irgendwie so geil ist. Du lässt dir deinen Verein nicht wegnehmen. Aber es passieren ja zwei Sachen dann trotzdem noch nach diesem Abstieg. Das eine ist, dass die Ausgliederung beschlossen wird. Das haben wir vorhin ja schon kurz angedeutet. Und das andere ist... Euphorisch beschlossen wird, muss man dazu sagen. Genau, das würde ich mir gleich nochmal von euch erklären lassen, wie das genau dazu kam. Und das andere, weil wir aber eben gerade bei diesem sportlichen Teil waren, es findet ja wieder ein unglaublicher Durchsatz an Spielern statt. Also zur Saison 2018, 2019 verpflichtet der 1. FC Kaiserslautern 30 Spieler lauternsfährmarkt.de und gibt 23 Spieler ab. Das heißt dann, 53 Spieler werden hier hin und her bewegt. Was ja auch... Also was es total erklärbar macht, warum es dann, sorry, Spoiler, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, nicht geklappt hat mit dem Wiederaufstieg in die 2. Liga. Aber dafür wird man halt dann in so einer Euphorie auch blind. Also jetzt in der Rückschau kannst du sagen, ja, also krass, also klar, das kann natürlich trotzdem gut gehen, aber was für ein irrer Umbruch das in diesem Verein war.
Und das ist auch, glaube ich... Da wurden natürlich extreme Fehler auch im Management getätigt. Diese ganzen Abgänge sind natürlich auch einfach darauf zurückzuführen, dass die Spieler keine Drittliga-Verträge hatten. Und selbstverständlich, da war der eine oder andere dabei, Sebastian Andersson zum Beispiel, der jetzt heute, oder was heißt heute, auch aktuell mit Union Berlin in der Bundesliga zeigt, dass er doch ganz gut Fußball spielen kann, der hätte wahrscheinlich keinen Drittliga-Vertrag unterschrieben. Aber du hättest zumindest eine Klausel verankern lassen müssen, dass du, was weiß ich, bei einem Drittliga-Abstieg wenigstens noch 500.000 Euro kriegst. Und selbst 200.000 Euro wären besser gewesen als gar nichts. Aber dass dir über 20 Spieler ablösefrei, also das ist ja eine Kapitalvernichtung seinesgleichen.
Und da muss man jetzt zumindest mal kurz über eine Personalie diskutieren, nämlich über Boris Nottson. Der ja doch als Sportdirektor quasi vehement in diese ganzen Vertragsgestaltungen mit eingebunden war. Und ich glaube, man kann durchaus sagen, dass es auch sein Verschulden war, dass quasi viele Spiele ablösefrei waren.
Auf jeden Fall, da ist keiner aus der sportlichen Ebene, ist davon frei zu sprechen. Und da hängt da natürlich auch Boris Nottson mit dem Boot.
Und Boris Nottson ist doch der ehemalige Chef-Scout von Lautern gewesen, der dann zum Sportdirektor wurde. Habe ich den richtig abgespricht?
Genau. Boris Nottson ist zu Beginn der Saison, ich meine, 2017, 18, nachdem Uwe Stöver zurückgetreten ist oder gekündigt hat, in einem Sommer, wo es ein ziemliches Vakuum gab, wo lange nicht klar war, wie wird sportlich erleitet. Dann hat Boris Nottson das erst kommissarisch gemacht, also quasi vor der Abstiegssaison. Er hat dann aber den Posten behalten und übernommen.
Und wie kommt es jetzt dann? Was ich noch sagen wollte, da ist auch der entscheidende Punkt. Wir haben das jetzt angesprochen, wieder so ein großer Personalwechsel. Die Mannschaft kann man ja sagen, einmal komplett ausgetauscht. Und dann kommt dieser Faktor hinzu, den Boris schon angesprochen hat. Dann verpflichtest du Spieler, die aber von Vereinen kommen, wo es ein ganz anderes Umfeld gibt, wo es diese Fanbase vielleicht nicht gibt, wo es diesen Druck nicht gibt. Das sind natürlich zum Teil dann schon auch gestandene Drittligaspieler gewesen, aber die, glaube ich, im Endeffekt trotzdem mit der Erwartungshaltung, die in Kaiserslautern vorherrscht, die wir ja auch schon auswählig besprochen haben, einfach nicht klar gekommen sind. Abgesehen natürlich, dass man auch die Zusammenstellung der Mannschaft als allgemein hinterfragt.
Das ist immer so ein großes Problem. Wenn wir gerade bei Boris Notzson waren, er hatte ein Händchen dafür, immer mal wieder gute Spieler zu finden und so weiter. Auch damals Sebastian Andersson, damals ja auch aus Schweden gekommen. Den hast du erstmal ausgraben müssen für die zweite Liga. Da hat er gut funktioniert. Doch dem FCK, nicht nur Boris Notzson, sondern auch davor und auch generell, die Chemie hat nie gestimmt in den Mannschaften. Das Händchen dafür, was fehlt dieser Mannschaft? Das hat so ein bisschen gefehlt. Es wurde zu sehr auf einzelne Charaktere geschaut und nicht auf das Gesamtkonstrukt.
Ich wollte jetzt auch um Gottes Willen nicht Boris Notzson die alleinige Schuld am sportlichen Niedergang geben. Das wäre auch recht unfair.
Das habe ich auch nicht so verstanden.
Das ist ja auch so eine Phase, wo der FCK auch durchaus auch mal Probleme hatte mit Spielern, die schon früher eine Verletzungshistorie hatten und dann wieder länger ausgefallen sind, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere. Das war doch auch in dieser Phase, also beim FCK. Es gab auch immer Gründe, dass man jetzt in der 3. Liga nicht den Durchmarsch direkt von Spieltag 1 an gestartet hat, so wie ich mich jetzt erinnere.
Genau, also einer der großen Hoffnungsträger für die 3. Liga war Lucas Balvis, den sie ein Jahr vorher von Sporting Lissabon ausgeliehen hatten. Litauischer Nationalspieler und durchaus ein sehr guter Angreifer, der nur eben vom Verletzungspech gebeutelt auf früher schon mal einen Kreuzbandriss gehabt hat. Und dass du so jemanden überhaupt für die 3. Liga begeistern konntest, war damals sehr sehr überraschend, aber es war damals ein Heimspiel gegen den Karlsruher SC, im September oder maximal im Oktober. Das heißt, wir können frühestens am 4. und 5. und 6. Spieltag gewesen sein, besser gesagt spätestens. Danach hat er sich wieder verletzt und von dieser Verletzung hat er sich bis heute nicht erholt.
Ja, und es droht die Sportinvalidität.
Oje, der FC Kaiserslautern, der macht sie einfach alle fertig. So, und dann haben wir neben dem Sportlichen, also es lief in der 3. Liga nicht gut. Michael Fronzig dann, ich glaube, nach dem 17. Spieltag, dann entlastet Sascha Hildmann, hat dann erstmal übernommen, aber es sollte eben nichts werden mit dem Aufstieg und zwischenzeitlich war man sogar mal auf Tabellenplatz 17 in der 3. Liga. Das ist jetzt die sportliche Komponente, aber wirtschaftlich war das ja jetzt dann dramatisch, und zwar noch dramatischer als der Abstieg aus der 1. Liga, weil wir haben weiter die hohe Stadiummiete, wir haben weiter Verbindlichkeiten, wir haben da mal 3 Millionen mit Quattrex und wir hatten ja auch schon eine Fananlei, die will ja auch irgendwann zurückbezahlt werden und jetzt kommt es zu einer euphorischen Ausgliederung, Sebastian. Erkläre mir das. Wie kann man eine Ausgliederung so frameen, dass alle sagen, ja, ja, go for it?
Naja, weil das in der Situation sozusagen der Strohhelm war, nachdem alle gegriffen haben und weil man das so verkauft hat, dass es quasi gar keine andere Möglichkeit mehr gibt, als jetzt bitte endlich auszugliedern, damit endlich die Investoren kommen können und groß in den FCK investieren können und natürlich nicht zuletzt auch sagen kann, hey, liebe Fans, wir werden eine sogenannte Fansäule für euch öffnen und dann könnt ihr selber Anteile an eurem Verein erwerben und ihr könnt quasi dazu beitragen zum sportlichen Erfolg und dieses ganze Geld, das wird uns wieder nach vorne bringen. Klar, ich meine, was willst du machen? Du bist sportlich am Abgrund, quasi am Tiefpunkt der Vereinsgeschichte sozusagen und natürlich musst du das dann positiv verkaufen. Ich meine, das ist ja nichts Neues, wir müssen ja nicht drüber reden, dass eine Ausgliederung natürlich höchst umstritten ist bei vielen Fußball-Fans, vor allem bei Ultras, die damit ein ganz großes Problem haben, weil sie sich einfach mit ganz anderen Werten identifizieren und diese ganze Kommerzialisierung des Fußballs kritisieren. Aber man hat es eben geschafft in dieser Phase, in der der Verein am Boden lag und in dem die Menschen einfach dafür zu begeistern, zu sagen, hey, das ist der letzte Sträum, den greifen wir jetzt und die Leute haben zugeschnappt und haben mit so und so vielen 90 Prozent, ich habe die Zahlen nicht mehr ganz im Kopf, zugestimmt. Also das war echt eine denkwürdige, außerordentliche Mitgliederversammlung damals. Ich erinnere mich da wirklich auch noch an den Thosen in Beifall, der dann da aufbrandete, als dann die Abstimmung bekannt wurde.
Ich will ein weiteres Zitat von dieser Mitgliederversammlung liefern. Ich habe ja vorhin gesagt, Michael Klatt hat das eine oder andere denkwürdige Zitat genannt und unter anderem hat er auf dieser Versammlung auch gesagt, man bräuchte nur eine oder man müsste das jetzt als Anschubfinanzierung nutzen und danach würde der Verein abgehen wie Schmitzkatze. In welche Richtung hat er nicht gesagt? Der damalige Aufsichtsratsvorsitzende Patrick Banff hat damals den Fans nicht versprochen, aber doch vorgemacht, man könnte doch in fünf oder sechs Jahren auf Augenhöhe mit Werder Bremen sein. Das könnte jetzt tatsächlich eintreffen, wenn man aufsteigt und später mit Bremen absteigt, aber ich glaube, das war damals nicht das, was Herr Banff im Kopf gehabt hat. Man muss zu der Mitgliederversammlung, zu dieser Euphorie auch sagen, das hat Martin Bader auch gut gekonnt. Martin Bader war jemand, der auch mit seinen Reden die Leute doch in seinen Bann ziehen konnte zu diesem Zeitpunkt. Noch später hat man ihm das nicht mal abgenommen, aber zu dem Zeitpunkt war er noch sehr unbelastet in Kaiserslautern. Und da hat er es geschafft, die Fans einfach auch mit ein bisschen Emotionalität einfach mitzureißen. Weil das ist eben so, in Kaiserslautern reißt du mit so ein bisschen Emotionalität sehr schnell sehr viele Leute mit.
Okay, das heißt, jetzt ist dann die Profi-Fußball-Abteilung ist jetzt ausgegliedert in eine KGAA, wenn ich es mir richtig gemerkt habe. Und ab jetzt ist man auf der Suche nach den Investoren oder dem Investor, der sagt, den FCK, den finde ich richtig geil. Ich butte hier Geld rein, weil jeder weiß, der FCK wird langfristig sowieso nicht in der dritten Liga bleiben, sondern eher aussteigen und vielleicht ja sogar zweimal ist das so richtig zusammengefasst.
Das ist richtig. Und jetzt rate, wer sofort gekommen ist und zugeschlagen hat?
Dabei hätte genau in dieser Phase jemand sofort zugeschlagen, wenn man ihm die Möglichkeit gegeben hätte. Und das ist eines der größten Versäumnisse, die man der Ära Glad Bader anrechnen muss. Und zwar diese nicht geöffnete Fan-Säule, die Sebastian schon angesprochen hat. Und zwar, um überhaupt diese große Zustimmung von den Mitgliedern zu erhalten, hat man ihnen ja vermeintlich gesehen relativ viel zugestanden, auch in diesem ganzen Konzept. Dieses Konzept der Ausliederung hat auf vier verschiedenen Säulen. Einem Großinvestor, einem stillen Kleubigen, ich sage es schon. Stille Teilhabe, die dann später zu stillen Kleubigen werden. Genau, Stille Teilhabe und eine dieser Säulen war eben auch eine Fansäule, wo die Fans schon für kleines Geld, schon für 100, 200, 300 Euro investieren hätten können. Und hätte man damals in dieser Euphorie, in diesem Sommer diese Fansäule aufgemacht, da wären mehrere Millionen Euro zusammengekommen. Trotz der Fananleihe 2013? Trotz der Fananleihe 2013 wären damals mehrere Millionen Euro zusammengekommen. Doch die Vorbereitung war, zumindest laut Michael Glatt, damals noch nicht so weit. Und später war der Grund immer wieder, dass die Bankenfinanzaufsicht das Ganze noch nicht freigibt und so weiter und so fort. Aber das hätte man anders planen müssen. Diese Fansäule hätte damals in dieser Euphorie aufgemacht werden müssen. Ob da jetzt in der Vorbereitung oder im Nachgang, wie auch immer. Man hätte es anders regeln müssen, weil so wurde eine große, große Chance verpasst. Im Nachhinein, aus der heutigen Sicht, müssen wir natürlich sagen, zum Glück wurde sie nicht aufgemacht, weil sonst wäre die Insolvenzmasse jetzt noch von den Millionen vieler, vieler Fans belastet. Und dann wäre die Stimmung eine andere.
Gut, aber deine These, dass Millionen zusammengekommen werden, die wird ja insofern gestützt, als ja dann 2019 die Betze an Laie 2 ist es jetzt dann gekommen ist, wo wir vorhin, gut, dass ich mir die Notizen gemacht habe vor zwei Stunden, wo über die Plattform Capilando die eine Million gesammelt wurde und dann über die Betze... Capilendo. Ah, siehst du mal, meine Schrift hat sich nicht verändert. Anders als mein Notiz-Machverhalten. Und dann eben die Betze an Laie mit zwei Millionen Euro. Und das waren jetzt aber dann schon Mittel, die man gebraucht hat, weil eben nicht gleich der Investor ums Eck kam und man den laufenden Betrieb aufrechterhalten musste. Oder wie hat man das verargumentiert?
Das ist genau richtig. Der Investor war eben nicht in Sicht. Und man hat zu Beginn des Jahres 2019 eine Finanzlücke von circa 11 bis 12 Millionen Euro kommuniziert. Die hat sich daraus zusammengesetzt, dass zum einen die Rückzahlung der Fernanlaie anstand 6 Millionen Euro. Und zum anderen das operative Defizit in der dritten Liga eben noch mal 5 bis 6 Millionen Euro beträgt. Das heißt, es war klar, du brauchst 11 Millionen Euro. Für einen Drittlig ist eine Menge Holz. Und dann ging es ja schon im Januar los. Es gab ja dann erste Investoren-Gerüchte auch um Mikhail Ponomarev, der in Krefeld beim KFC Uerdingen auch als Geldgeber mit drin ist. Und recht schnell kam ja dann auch im Frühjahr, Februar, März der Name Flavio Becker aufs Parkett.
Sebastian, ich habe das Gefühl, wir haben dieses Gespräch schon immer geführt.
Ja, wir haben das auch so ähnlich schon mal geführt, das stimmt.
Genau, also wir haben dazu einen Kurzpass aufgenommen. Das ist der vorhin angesprochene Kurzpass. Den werde ich natürlich auch in den Show Notes verlinken. Ganz so ins Detail müssen wir jetzt nicht mehr gehen, aber magst du noch mal in zwei, drei Sätzen kurz sagen, wer ist Flavio Becker und wie ging es denn eigentlich aus? Das wussten wir damals nämlich noch nicht.
In aller Kürze, Flavio Becker ist ein luxemburgischer Geschäftsmann, der auch schon mit verschiedenen Investments im Sport aufgetreten ist, der in Luxemburg einen Verein quasi zum dauerhaften Meister gemacht hat, in dem er da sehr viel Geld reingesteckt hat. Und der hat irgendwann Interesse bekundet und lange Rede kurzer Sinn. Er hat lange mit seinem Interesse kolportiert, hat auch mehr oder weniger offensiv versucht, auch schon mitzureden, hat aber eigentlich, oder was heißt eigentlich, hat dann nie wirklich investiert bis eben auf das vorhin schon angesprochene Geld, was eben nur, weil der FCK diesen Kredit in Anspruch genommen hat und er dafür gebürgt hat, nur deswegen hängt er da jetzt als Gläubiger mit drin. Also das ist einfach eine sehr, sehr, sehr schwierige Geschichte mit Flavio Becker, der sich auch zwischenzeitlich mal auf dem Betzenberg gezeigt hat, aber das war auch einfach von Anfang an eine sehr umstrittene Person, weil das Vorgehen bei den anderen Vereinen, ich sag mal, zumindest diskutabel war.
Das Problem war eben, dass sich die Vereinsführung aber relativ schnell auf Flavio Becker als einzige Lösung, oder als vermeintlich einzige Lösung, festgelegt hat und sich damit halt gnadenlos verzockt hat. Jeder wird sich noch an die Vorgänge, oder zumindest vage an die Vorgänge im vergangenen Sommer rund um Kaiserslautern erinnern. Man muss es wirklich als eine einzige Schlammschlacht, eine monatelange Schlammschlacht bezeichnen. Rücktritte, geforderte Rücktritte, gezwungene Rücktritte. Auch Quatrex spielt jetzt hier wieder eine Rolle, weil Quatrex damals eine sehr prominente Rolle gespielt hat, weil zumindest wurde es so kommuniziert vom Verein. Es gab eine konkurrierende Investorengruppe, um es jetzt mal so zu bezeichnen, die gerne auch investiert hätte oder möglicherweise investieren wollte. Hätte der FCK dieser Gruppe den Zuschlag gegeben, wäre Quatrex ausgestiegen und hätte dem FCK kein weiteres Geld gegeben. Das heißt, auch Quatrex hat den FCK zu Flavio Becker in die Richtung getränkt. Warum das geschehen ist...
Klar, die wollen lieber mit einem Investoren, mit dem man ja auch dann selber vielleicht schneller den Dialog suchen kann, als mit einer Investorengruppe, die heterogen ist, in ihrer Entscheidungsfindung reden, oder?
Und letztendlich, ja, das könnte in diese Richtung gehen. Und letztendlich, Sebastian hat es ja schon gesagt, es ist nie zu einem Vertragsabschluss mit Flavio Becker über den Fluss von Eigenkapital gekommen, sondern letztendlich hat er nur als Bürger bereitgestanden, 2,6 Millionen Euro. Und das restliche Geld kam unter anderem von Lagardere, kam unter anderem wieder von Quatrix. Und so konnte die Lücke halt tatsächlich am Ende gefüllt werden. Doch dadurch, dass die Schulden halt so die 20 Millionen Euro-Schallmauer durchbrochen haben, ja, war das Sterben auf Raten jetzt quasi besiegelt.
Wir müssen eine Sache noch ansprechen, und ich glaube, wir müssen sie auch kurz ansprechen, weil es jetzt glaube ich hier auch zu weit führen würde, jede einzelne Personalie ins Detail zu besprechen. Aber was beim FCK seit jeher eine große Rolle gespielt hat, ist der Aufsichtsrat und auch die Persönlichkeiten, die in dem Aufsichtsrat aktiv waren. Es hatte quasi schon fast Tradition, dass Personen, die im Aufsichtsrat saßen, versucht haben, sich ins operative Geschäft einzumischen. Und auch teilweise mit ganz großen Versprechungen angetreten sind, was sie denn alles machen wollen, um den FCK wieder in die Erfolgsspur zu führen und wo sie Investoren herbringen wollen und was auch immer. Also ich denke da an einen Herrn Regekampf und auch den vorhin schon erwähnten Herrn Banff. Das ist einfach eine Geschichte, die seit jeher ein sehr, sehr großes Problem für den FCK war. Nämlich, dass es auch rund um den Verein herum verschiedene Interessengruppen gibt, die versuchen, über den Aufsichtsrat Einfluss auf den Verein auszuüben. Wie gesagt, das wird jetzt zu weit führen, wenn wir jede einzelne Personalie ins Detail diskutieren. Aber der Aufsichtsrat spielt da eben eine sehr, sehr große Rolle.
Und da gab es ja jetzt auch nochmal eine Veränderung. Da ist aktuell Markus Merck, der im Aufsichtsrat ist, sogar Aufsichtsratsvorsitzender. Er hat zumindest die meisten Stimmen bekommen im Dezember 2019. War der denn vorher schon involviert beim 1. FC Kaiserslautern? Oder ist das jetzt jemand, der von außen kommt und versucht, etwas zu retten, was ihm am Herzen liegt?
Markus Merck war in den letzten Jahren immer nah dran am Verein. Und es gab auch vor einigen Jahren das genaue Jahr, weiß ich jetzt nicht, könnte aber roundabout 2016 gewesen sein. Hatte er sich schon mal angeboten für eine Rolle im operativen Geschäft damals. Aber dieses Jahr bzw. Ende vergangenen Jahres im Dezember waren ja die Aufsichtsratswahlen, ist er neu hinzugekommen. Die Vereinsführung Michael Gladmartin Baader hatte sich halt durch diese ganzen Investorenverhandlungen im Sommer so was vergaloppiert, dass sie letztendlich sich auch mit dem Aufsichtsrat, was Sebastian ja gerade schon angesprochen hatten, es war alles zum Ende des Sommers, zu Beginn des Herbstes alles in dieser Form eigentlich nicht mehr tragbar. Und nach und nach war dann auch klar, der Vertrag von Martin Baader wird nicht verlängert. Die entsprechenden Aufsichtsräte sind zurückgetreten. Auch Michael Glad hat dann aus eigenem Willen gekommen und hat gesagt, er geht zum Jahresende. Und dann war klar, der Verein braucht eine komplett neue Führung und dann ist eben Markus Merkens spät gekommen.
Das hätte ich eigentlich wissen müssen, weil er ja der aktuelle ist.
Man muss zur Person Markus Merk sagen, er ist natürlich ein Urlauterer, der auch nicht müde wird, zu betonen, dass er da 200 Meter entfernt vom Betzenberg groß geworden ist. Und sein Vater war schon lange Jahre beim FCK jemand, der einfach bekannt war, der die Schiedsrichter betreut hat bei den Spielen. Man könnte sagen, Markus Merk hat dieses, gerade speziell zu Zeiten von Stefan Kunz schon zitierte, Herzblut mitgebracht und deutlich gemacht, dass es ihm jetzt ein persönlich großes Anliegen ist, diesen Verein, der ihm natürlich sehr am Herzen liegt, wie er sagt, nach vorne zu bringen und sich dazu engagieren.
Markus Merk und Rainer Kessler, den du eben schon angesprochen hast, dass Rainer Kessler auch langjährig dem FCK sehr nahe, sehr verbunden ist. Sein Vater Hubert Kessler war in den 90ern schon mal Präsident des FCKs. Die beiden haben sich quasi als Team dann aufgestellt, haben sich Kompetenz mit ins Boot geholt, haben einen neuen Aufsichtsrat zusammengestellt, wurden dann ja auch gewählt und haben dann eben Sören Oliver-Vogt, den jetzigen Geschäftsführer, im Amt platziert. Und ich glaube, Sebastian, das kann man schon so sagen, es gab tatsächlich im vergangenen Dezember keine Alternative. Also hätte sich diese Gruppe, sich nicht dieser schier aussichtslosen Aufgabe angenommen, ja, ich weiß nicht, wie es ausgegangen wäre.
Ich weiß es auch nicht. Also das war, ich weiß nicht, wie oft ich jetzt noch sagen will, der letzte Strohhalm oder die letzte Patrone. Das ist in dem Zusammenhang auch schon ganz oft genannt worden. Aber das war alternativlos, so wie es Moritz gesagt hat, das war alternativlos. Und da sind wir wieder bei dem Punkt, es war zum einen alternativlos und zum anderen hast du mit Markus Merck halt eben auch einen Namen, mit dem die Leute was anfangen können. Und es ist einfach so, dass die Leute ab und zu glaube ich jemanden brauchen, den sie kennen, dem sie vertrauen, dem gegenüber sie einfach positiv gestimmt sind. Und das war Markus Merck in dem Moment. Und deswegen, man muss sich ja vorstellen, der Aufsichtsrat besteht aus fünf Personen, aber es wurde immer nur von Team Merck gesprochen. Die ganzen anderen Personen, da sitzt noch ein Jurist drin, da sitzt mit Martin Wagner auch ein ehemaliger Spieler drin. Aber es wurde immer nur oder wird eigentlich immer noch von Team Merck gesprochen, weil einfach diese Person Merck, da sind wir wieder beim Stichwort Strahlkraft, Strahlkraft hat. Das ist glaube ich auch was, danach haben sich die Leute zu dem Zeitpunkt auch gesehen, dass da jemand kommt, der sie an die Hand nimmt und der ihnen zeigt, wie der Verein eben nach vorne marschieren kann. Aber ich glaube, ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich glaube, sie haben sich, sie wussten, dass es schwer wird, aber ich glaube nicht, dass sie wussten, dass es so schwer wird. Und zwar sowohl Markus Merck im Aufsichtsrat als auch Sören Oliver Vogt als Geschäftsführer. Ich glaube, sie haben zwischendurch gemerkt und vor allem haben sie es gemerkt an der Stelle, über die wir glaube ich auch noch ein bisschen sprechen müssen, wenn es um die Verhandlungen zur Stadionpacht ging. Nämlich die Verhandlungen mit der Stadt. Das war einfach ein sehr langer, zeitaufwendiger und sehr zermürbender Prozess, der unglaublich lange gedauert hat. Da wurde über Monate debattiert und gestritten über das Thema Stadionpacht, bis man sich da einig war. Und da muss man an der Stelle eigentlich auch nochmal sagen, es wurde vorhin schon mal erwähnt, Grundproblem bei der Stadionpacht ist bei dieser ganzen Stadiongeschichte, dass nie davon ausgegangen wurde, dass der FCK mal nicht mehr Bundesliga spielt. Das heißt, ganz ursprünglich gab es nur einen Vertrag, der eine Summe festgelegt hat für die Bundesliga. Und dann musste man sich in der zweiten Liga schon überlegen, ach scheiße, mit dem Geld, was wir hier verdienen, können wir das ja gar nicht stemmen. Also musste da schon nachverhandelt werden, die Pacht musste reduziert werden. Und in der dritten Liga ist recht, also wir reden von einem Ursprungsbetrag von 3,2 Millionen Euro und sind jetzt in der dritten Liga, hat der FCK die letzten zwei Jahre 425.000 Euro Pacht bezahlt und soll jetzt in den kommenden zwei Jahren 625.000 Euro zahlen. Die Differenz daraus muss die Stadt ausgleichen, also nur mal um die Dimensionen klarzumachen.
Um da noch ein Detail hinzuzufügen, die Stadt hat diesen Kauf vom Stadion damals komplett fremdfinanziert. Das heißt, es geht um einen Kredit in Höhe von 66 Millionen Euro und die Stadt zahlt für diesen Kredit jährlich allein 2,8 Millionen Euro Zinsen. Und mit der Bundesliga-Miete von 3,2 Millionen Euro wäre das selbstverständlich gedeckt. Aber aktuell haben wir ja hier eine Lücke von 2,4 Millionen Euro, die die Stadt jährlich aus ihrem ohnehin schon sehr devizitären Haushalt begleichen muss.
Kann er nicht Quattrex einspringen?
Aber deswegen kommt auch immer der Bund der Steuerzahler um die Ecke.
Ja, natürlich. Das ist ja auch richtig. Das sind ja öffentliche Gelder. Aber habe ich das jetzt richtig verstanden, dass man, als man dann in der zweiten Liga die Pacht für die zweite Liga verhandelt hat, weil man gemerkt hat, oh, wir hatten ja in unserem Vertrag nur eine Erstliga-Pacht drin, dass man dann nicht damals auch dann schon eine Drittliga-Variante reingepfandelt hat. Ey Leute, manchmal möchte ich hier auch wirklich irgendwas an die Wand werfen. Das ist doch keine wahre Sache. Also manchmal haben sie es sich aber auch wirklich selber zu schwer gemacht, oder?
Ja, man ist halt immer davon ausgegangen, dass das wird schon wieder. Das ist jetzt hier irgendwie mal wieder ein Ausrutscher, das wird schon wieder.
Das war ja die ganze Geschichte der letzten 20 Jahre. Ja, einfach nur ein Es wird schon wieder ist in Sport und Ergebnisse und Finanzen gekossen. Und jetzt ist ja die aktuelle Situation so für alle Hörerinnen und Hörer, die es nicht vor Augen haben. Also es wird auch in dieser Saison nicht mit dem Wiederaufstieg klappen. Ein weiteres Drittliga-Jahr ist drin. Immerhin, man konnte sich unter Boris Schommers, der dann für Sascha Hildmann übernommen hat, konnte man sich wieder von den Abstiegsplätzen entfernen und liegt jetzt im gesicherten unteren Tabellendrittel. Kann man das so sagen? Na ja, es sieht jetzt halbwegs okay aus. Aber jetzt kam ja Corona mit dazu. Und jetzt schließen wir den Bogen zum Anfang der Sendung. Eure Einschätzung, das kann jetzt natürlich nur höchst subjektiv sein, hätte es nicht ohne Corona denselben Schuldenschnitt geben müssen. Und das war eben dann, was wir vorhin auch schon angedeutet hatten, die Gelegenheit, die man jetzt dann auch vielleicht sogar danken angenommen hat, weil das, was ihr vorhin gesagt habt, mit den Altlasten, die mal weg müssen, also das haben wir in den letzten zwei Stunden gelernt. Ja, das ist so, die müssen weg.
Doch, ganz genauso wie du es sagst, muss man es eigentlich sehen. Der Schuldenschnitt hätte schon früher kommen müssen. Es ist einfach beschleunigt worden, dadurch, dass Corona kam. Und man muss sich ja auch vor Augen halten, die dritte Liga ist ja wie keine andere Profiliga in Deutschland ganz krass auch von den Zuschauereinnahmen abhängig, weil es ja einfach da nur ein Bruchteil des Fernsehgeldes gibt, wie in den ersten beiden Ligen. Und sobald du dann gerade auch als Verein wie der FCK, der ja in der dritten Liga Primus ist, was Zuschauerzahlen angeht, was er auch sein muss in dem großen Stadion, da ist man so stark auf die Ticketverkäufe angewiesen, dass das natürlich schon nochmal ein harter Einschnitt war.
Ganz klar. Ich kann mich dem nur anschließen. Die Sanierung, in welcher Form auch immer, die war zwingend notwendig. Und dessen waren sich aber auch Sören Olli Vogt, Markus Merck und Co. bewusst. Und sicherlich, wenn Sören Vogt aktuell ja sagt, es hat vor Corona aussichtsreiche Verhandlungen gegeben mit möglichen Geldgebern, dann war das sicherlich auch irgendwo alles an den Schuldenschnitt gebunden. Weil es heißt ja jetzt auch von der Vereinsführung, wir finden keinen Investor bei diesem Schuldenberg. Und diesen Investor hättest du auch im Februar nicht gefunden, selbstverständlich. Und Corona hat dir natürlich diese ganzen Verhandlungen verhagelt. Aber letztendlich musst du vielleicht unter Umständen tatsächlich jetzt froh sein, dass dieser Punktabzug ausgesetzt worden ist, weil hätten sich die Verhandlungen nicht zu Gunsten des FC Kaiserslautern erschlossen und du hättest 9 Punkte abgezogen bekommen im Falle eines Insolvenzverfahrens, dann würdest du unter Umständen accesseil in der Regionalliga spielen und über die Möglichkeit, dass der 1. FC Kaiserslautern in der Regionalliga spielt, da brauchen wir gar nicht nachdenken, das geht nicht. Genau, wegen der laufenden Kosten, wegen dem Stadion, wegen dem Gesamtpaket.
Und du musst auch mal schauen, die 9 Punkte, das hätte natürlich ziemlich viel ausgemacht. Wir reden jetzt heute, stand 19. Juni, da hatte der FC K 7 Punkte Vorsprung auf den Abstiegsplatz. Dann kannst du dir ausrechnen, was bei minus 9 Punkten los wäre. Es ist so schon der Klassenerhalt noch nicht sicher.
Okay, jetzt gehen wir mal davon aus, wir werden uns ja sowieso im Rasenfunk begleiten. Bis zum 30. 31. Oktober schafft man den Schuldenschnitt. Ob das dann irgendwie so ist, dass man 90 Prozent der Schulden erlassen bekommt, wie auch immer man sich da einigt. Und dann ist auch das Tor offen für den Investor oder die Fans als Investoren oder eine Investorengruppe, wer auch immer dann da reinkommen möchte und Geld rein gibt. Wie optimistisch seid ihr zwei denn? So ein bisschen als abschließende Frage. Sebastian, du musst vorlegen, dass wenn ich in fünf Jahren nochmal bei euch anrufe und sage, Jungs, ihr erinnert euch doch an unser Lautern-Tribünengespräch. Was ist denn inzwischen passiert? Wie optimistisch bist du, dass man dann sagen kann, okay, Lautern ist wieder in der zweiten Liga, hat sich im Profifußball etabliert und das ganze Hamsterrad ging nicht wieder von vorne los?
Machst du auch Champions League-Tribünengespräche?
Ich verspreche dir hiermit, wenn Lautern in die Champions League kommt, dann werde ich die Champions League-Saison von Lautern in einem Tribünengespräch begleiten.
Sehr schön, Spaß beiseite, das ist so ein bisschen der Running Gag hier in Kaiserslautern, weil man sagt immer, sobald da mal irgendwas positiv ist, dann sprechen die Leute oder die ersten schon wieder von Champions League. Das ist übrigens auch was, was Herr Becker, glaube ich, angepeilt hatte, gerne Champions League zu spielen. Also nein, ich bin in der Tat relativ optimistisch, dass das funktionieren kann. Zum einen, weil es keine andere Alternative gibt, zum anderen aber auch, weil ich glaube, dass die Voraussetzungen in Kaiserslautern nicht die schlechtesten sind. Auch wenn der Standort an sich sicher seine Schwächen hat. Ich habe es ja vorhin versucht, so ein bisschen aufzuzählen. Aber man muss ja mal sehen, du hast in Kaiserslautern ein sehr breites Fundament, auf dem das alles steht. Und das bezieht sich nicht nur auf das Stadion, sondern du hast nichtsdestotrotz immer noch eine sehr große Fanbase. Du hast eine Bekanntheit immer noch über Deutschland hinaus. Ich meine, ich will jetzt den FCK nicht in den Himmel loben und nicht mit Bayern oder Dortmund vergleichen. Aber für einen Drittligisten ist das schon sehr auffällig. Und ich glaube einfach, wenn sich da jetzt die richtigen Leute finden und Geld in die Hand nehmen und es auch vernünftig in die Hand nehmen und nicht sagen, wir pumpen jetzt 3 Millionen in den Kader und verpflichten noch mal Asa Karadas oder Nureddin Daham oder so. Die FC K Fans ziehen sich gerade freiwillig die Nägel raus. Also wirklich mit Hand und Fuß und mit Sachverstand da rangehen, dann glaube ich, kannst du den FC K nachhaltig wieder in höheres Fähren führen. Und ich glaube, wenn du in 5 Jahren nochmal anfragen würdest, dann bin ich mir ziemlich sicher, dass wir zumindest über eine Zweitligasaison sprechen. Und ich glaube, die Fans haben allen Grund zur Hoffnung, aber es bleibt ihnen auch gar nichts anderes übrig. Sie müssen so optimistisch sein, anders geht es nicht. Ja gut, sie haben ja sonst nichts anderes. Okay, jetzt kann man wieder sagen, in Kaiserslautern gibt es nichts außer den FC K, aber es ist tatsächlich nur das Abschied.
Nee, nee, so meinte ich das jetzt gar nicht. Ich meinte das einfach nur in Bezug auf den FC K. Also klar musst du hoffen.
Das stimmt. Aber es wäre trotzdem auch, wenn man es anders interpretiert, was du gesagt hast, auch gar nicht so falsch, weil auch das hat Dirk Eichelbaum bei seinem Amtsantritt gesagt, dass es kaum eine andere Stadt in Deutschland gibt, die so sehr eigentlich nur mit Fußball identifiziert wird. Oder was fällt dir denn außer dem FCK bei Kaiserslautern noch ein? Wahrscheinlich relativ, ja okay, Opel vielleicht noch, aber ansonsten ist das nicht viel. Von daher, ich bin relativ optimistisch, aber ich sag auch, du hast diese ganzen Ehrungen und Wendungen, die wir jetzt in den vergangenen Monaten, Minuten und Stunden besprochen haben, mitbekommen. Man weiß nie, wer noch um die Ecke kommt. Man weiß nie, ob nicht doch noch einer einen Schlüssel zu irgendeinem Kellerraum findet, der bisher noch ungeöffnet war. Und was weiß man, was da vielleicht noch für alt ist?
Dort vielleicht einen bunten Blumenstrauß an Finanzierungsmöglichkeiten findet Sebastian. Das ist übrigens auch. Ich musste es jetzt einfach mal noch unterbringen, weil das ist noch ein legendäres Zitat von Michael Klapp.
Und damit gebe ich den Ball auch gerne weiter an Moritz.
Ich könnte das zum Großteil auch so unterschreiben, wie es ja Sepp jetzt gesagt hat. Aber damit ich mich hier jetzt nicht wiederhole, gehe ich ein bisschen in eine andere Richtung. Man muss differenzieren. Was die wirtschaftliche Situation angeht, bin ich sehr optimistisch, dass der FCK dieses Insolvenzplanverfahren in dieser Art und Weise, wie er sich das vorstellt, über die Bühne bringen kann und auch tatsächlich danach den ein oder anderen Investor findet. Dann ist zumindest auf wirtschaftlicher Basis die Grundlage geschaffen, damit du wieder Erfolg haben kannst. Doch die wirtschaftliche Grundlage ist im Sport eben nicht alles. Es braucht in Kaiserslautern zwei weitere Punkte. Zum einen, auch jetzt noch mal ab vom Rasen, die Grabenkämpfe, die es jetzt seit Jahrzehnten im Umfeld gibt, die nicht immer offensichtlich, aber stets latent, auch in der jetzigen Situation vorhanden sind, immer noch wird mit den Hufen gescharrt und der eine versucht, da noch was zu machen und da nicht noch ein bisschen mehr Macht zu kriegen. Das ist auch aktuell in der jetzigen Phase immer noch vorhanden. Das macht die Vereinsführung um Sören Olli-Fogt und Markus Merck aktuell sehr gut. Die schaffen es, diese verschiedenen Lager auch zu moderieren und schaffen es, dem Verein aktuell eine gute Außendarstellung zu geben. Und das ist das 9+, also das, damit steht und fällt auch alles, weil wenn du wieder anfängst, dich selbst zu zerfleischen, dann kannst du auch keinen sportlichen Erfolg haben. Das ist der eine Punkt. Und da bin ich verhalten optimistisch, aber optimistisch, weil ich das Markus Merck und Søren Oliver Vogt zutraue, dass sie das schaffen, diese Probleme zu managen. Und dann müssen diese regelmäßigen Fehlgriffe auf dem Transfermarkt aufhören. Du brauchst einen klaren sportlichen Plan. Du musst das mit einem Trainer entwickeln. Diese Higher and Fire Politik muss endlich ein Ende finden. Und dann bin ich ganz bei Sebastian. Ich glaube, dass wir in fünf Jahren mindestens über einen Zweitligisten sprechen. Und ob es dann mehr ist, das hängt auch von den Entwicklungen ab. Und da spielt der Faktor Glück auch wieder eine ganz große Rolle. Aber ich glaube nicht, wenn wir uns in fünf Jahren unterhalten, dass wir uns über einen Drittligisten unterhalten. Weil über einen Drittligisten können wir uns in fünf Jahren wahrscheinlich nicht mehr unterhalten. Weil selbst mit neuem Geld, selbst mit frischem Geld, der FCK macht in der dritten Liga jedes Jahr 6 Millionen Euro Verlust. Das will kein Investor über die nächsten fünf Jahre tragen. Das heißt, der Aufstieg ist zwangsläufig Pflicht.
Und eine Sache will ich an der Stelle auch noch anfügen, über die Vereinsführung. Moritz hat es gerade schon gesagt, was sie ganz gut hingekriegt haben und was sie auch ganz gut hingekriegt haben, ist, dass sie es besser steuern, was wann an die Öffentlichkeit gerät. Ich meine, natürlich ist es jetzt, wenn man mal rein aus der Sicht eines Journalisten spricht, die wir alle sind, natürlich ist es für uns immer super, wenn viel an die Öffentlichkeit kommt. Aber es gab Phasen in Kaiserslautern, da gab es Aufsichtsratssitzungen, die waren noch nicht zu Ende, da haben die ersten Tageszeitungen schon über Inhalte berichtet. Es gab Gespräche zwischen dem 1. FC Kaiserslautern und der Stadt, die waren kaum zu Ende, da wurde schon drüber berichtet. Die Art und Weise, wie kommuniziert wurde, das war nicht in Ordnung. Da sind Sachen zu früh nach außen gedrungen, was zu sehr viel Verunsicherung bei den Fans geführt hat. Die jetzige Vereinsführung hat es geschafft, diese Kommunikation klarer zu strukturieren, klarer zu benennen, wer, wann, was, wem sagt. Das hat auch dazu beigetragen, dass ein bisschen mehr Ruhe reingekommen ist in dieses Umfeld, das muss man ganz klar sagen.
Es hat noch ein interessanter Nebenaspekt, da können wir leider nicht mehr tiefer drauf eingehen, weil jetzt sogar euer sehr, sehr weit gewähltes Zeitbudget langsam erschöpft ist. Aber der 1. FC Kaiserslautern gehört ja auch zu den Vereinen, die, meinem Eindruck nach, zumindest auch schon sehr früh eine lebhafte Online-Community hatte. Der Betzebrennt ist da natürlich ganz wichtig. Die verschiedenen FCK-Podcasts, die es gab und in denen gerüchteweise sogar hier Anwesende auch früher aktiv waren, sind da ganz wichtig. Das spielt da ja auch noch mal eine Rolle. Die Fans sind nicht nur sehr interessiert am Verein, sondern sie...
Tragen ihn.
Ja, sie tragen ihn. Zum Teil hatte ich aber auch das Gefühl, es gab Zeiten beim 1. FC Kaiserslautern, wo gerade kritisch Nachfragende und selber vielleicht auch mal nachforschende Fans ein wichtiges Element in der ganzen Vereinskultur waren, weil auch die dann neue Erkenntnisse zutage gefördert haben oder weil die eben die entscheidenden Fragen gestellt haben, die dann auch wieder von Journalistinnen und Journalisten aufgenommen wurden. Also ein sehr aktives Umfeld auch, nicht nur kritisch, sondern auch sehr aktiv.
Absolut, aber das, was du ansprichst, das Kritische, das ist schon auch sehr ausgeprägt und das hat natürlich seinen Grund, weil die Leute sind misstrauisch geworden.
Logisch, klar, gleich auch.
Das muss man sagen, sie wurden teilweise einfach verarscht, kann man sagen, oder enttäuscht. Und deswegen hat sich eine sehr kritische Grundhaltung bei einigen mittlerweile etabliert. Und das ist ja auch nicht unbedingt schlecht. Man kann ja auch Fan von etwas sein und es trotzdem kritisch hinterfragen. Aber die Fans tragen einfach so, so, so einen so großen Teil dazu bei, dass der FCK trotz aller Widrigkeiten diese Voraussetzungen hat. Und wenn man sich mal überlegt und das Ganze vergleicht mit Standorten, nehmen wir mal Hoffenheim, der Vergleich hinkt natürlich, weil die nochmal andere Voraussetzungen hatten, auch finanziell. Aber was du in so einen Standort reinpumpen musst, um erst mal Infrastruktur zu schaffen, die vorher nicht da war, um eine Fangemeinde dir langsam groß zu ziehen, die es vorher nicht gab, die jetzt auch immer noch nicht besonders groß ist, aber bist du an so einem Standort mit einem Sportinvestment, was verdienst, da musst du noch viel, viel mehr Zeit und Geld mitbringen, als wenn du jetzt hingehst und sagst, ok, ich nehme diese vorhandenen Strukturen in Kaiserslautern, du musst da sicher auch viel reinstecken. Wir haben über das Tolle Stadion gesprochen, das ist auch nicht nur toll. Da muss auch dringend an einigen Stellen mal was nachgebessert werden. Es ist ohne Zweifel ein schönes Stadion, aber es ist nicht perfekt. Und da muss auch Geld in die Hand genommen werden. Aber wenn du das am Standort Kaiserslautern machst, kannst du aus Sicht eines Sportinvestoren meiner Meinung nach mit weniger Invest einen größeren Output generieren, als an einem anderen Standort.
Das ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt, weil das ist ja auch das, was die Geschäftsführung aktuell sagt. Der FCK ist gesetzter Fall, die Schulden sind weg. Ein wirklich höchst interessantes Investment im deutschen Fußball. Weil du zudem auch mit dem Sprung von der zweiten in die dritte Liga auch theoretisch kurzfristig Gewinn machen kannst, auch als Investor. Und langfristig mit dieser Fanbase im Rücken. Diese Fanbase, dieses Umfeld, das Ganze rund um den Verein ist auch der einzige Grund oder einer der Gründe, einer der wichtigsten Gründe, warum eben gerade die Investoren trotz dieser schweren Lage überhaupt Interesse an diesem Verein haben.
Es ist eine der Mitglieder der stärksten Vereine in Deutschland. Also im Ranking aller Sportvereine auf Platz 34 mit 17.500 Mitgliedern. Damit liegt man zum Beispiel vor dem 1. FSV Mainz und 5, vor Hansa Rostock, vor Arminia Bielefeld. Das sind so alles Vereine, die dahinter kommen. Und ich finde das schön, das hätte ich gar nicht gedacht, dass wir am Ende dieser Sendung dann im Grunde bei einem kurzen Marketing-Segment von euch beiden lernen, wo ihr kommenden Investoren, die das hier ja auf jeden Fall hören werden, in ihrer Recherche dann schon mal schmackhaft macht, dieses Filetstück lautern. Wenn erst mal die mardigen Schulden alle weggepult sind, dann ist es wieder ein äußerst saftiges Stück Fleisch der Betze. Gut, ich danke euch beiden. Das hat mich wirklich nochmal sehr, also es hat mich auch erschüttert, ich bin ehrlich. Aber es hat mich auch sehr erhält, mit euch nochmal über die letzten Jahre beim FC K zu sprechen. Und vor allem habe ich jetzt das Gefühl, mit allem besser umgehen zu können, was jetzt kommen wird. Denn da wird ja noch so einiges passieren bei Lautern. Und ich kann das jetzt besser einordnen. Das verdanke ich nur euch beiden. Deswegen ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank an dich, lieber Sebastian. Sebastian Zobel, at twitcher redo auf Twitter. Man kann ihn auch hören im Nur der FC K Podcast und beim SWR ja sowieso. Danke dir, Sebastian, dass du mal wieder mit dabei warst im Rasenfunk.
Sehr, sehr gerne, Max. Und ich hoffe tatsächlich, dass wir nicht erst in 5 Jahren wieder miteinander sprechen, sondern auch schon früher.
ist schon immer im Hinterkopf abgespeichert.
Absolut. Spätestens am 31.10. Danke dir, Max. Hat mir immer sehr, sehr viel Spaß gemacht. Und was auch nicht untergehen darf, an dieser Stelle, ganz unabhängig vom FCK, möchte ich einmal ein ganz, ganz, ganz großes Lob an dich aussprechen. An die viele Arbeit, die du dir mit dem Rasenfunk machst, und was daraus geworden ist. Wir haben uns ja kennengelernt, da war daran noch gar nichts zu denken. Das stimmt ja. In einer Zeit, und was du da aus dem Boden gestampft hast. Also wirklich. Und bei dem Hintergrund, den ja auch alle kennen, den du hast, und was da familiär noch alles abgeht. Wirklich Hut ab, allergrößten Respekt. Das muss auch mal gesagt werden.
Ach, Mensch, Sebastian, das musst du nicht unehrgesagt werden. Aber gut, ja, danke dir.
Doch, das muss auch mal unehrgesagt werden, Max.
Na gut, also vielen herzlichen Dank. Und so, wie der FCK ja von seinen Fans getragen wird, ist das ja beim Rasenfunk genauso. Wenn die Leute nicht spenden würden freiwillig, dann gäbe es das Ding hier auch gar nicht mehr.
Und das kann man in dieser Konsequenz auch so behaupten, ohne dass es eine Lüge wäre. Deswegen reiche ich den Dank mal weiter. Und ich bedanke mich außerdem bei Moritz Kreilinger vom Kicker EdM-Kreilinger, der nicht nur hier ein grandioses Debüt abgegeben hat, sondern auch im Kicker selbst die ganzen Geschichten noch aufarbeitet. Da kann man sich, wenn ihr das jetzt hier schnell hört, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, könnt ihr euch auf einen Artikel von ihm in der Montagsausgabe freuen. Also in der Montagsausgabe vom, wir sind jetzt im Juni 2020. Die Tribünengespräche werden ja noch sehr lange gehört, ist mir gerade bewusst geworden. Moritz, wie dankt dir, dass du mit dabei warst im Rasenfunk.
Max, vielen, vielen Dank für die Einladung. Es hat mir sehr viel Spaß mit euch beiden gemacht. Auch mit Sebastian habe ich noch nie in dieser Ausführlichkeit die letzten 20 Jahre des 1. FC Kaiserslautern zerlegt. Es hat Spaß gemacht, war an dem einen oder anderen Punkt noch mal sehr bedenklich, wenn man zurückschaut. Aber wie gesagt, gerne, vielen Dank für die Einladung. Danke, Max, danke, Sebastian. Und ich hoffe doch auch, dass wir uns spätestens kurz nach dem 31. Oktober wieder zusammenfinden.
Na logisch, wir machen das jetzt einfach in der Konstellation immer weiter. Ihr seid jetzt meine Go-To-Guys, ihr zwei. In diesem Sinne, danke euch beiden und danke euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, für eure Aufmerksamkeit und für die Unterstützung. Ihr könnt uns unter rasenfunk.de/unterstützen. Unterstützen mit direkten Spenden. Oder ihr könnt auch über kiosk.rasenfunk.de Merchandise vom Rasenfunk erwerben. Das ist auch eine Möglichkeit, uns finanzielle Hilfe zukommen zu lassen. Danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Ich hoffe, den vielen Nachfragenden ist dieses Tribünengespräch gerecht geworden. In diesem Sinne macht's gut. Bis bald. Das war das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch.
Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Punkthäuser.